Why is it so quiet?
Why are you guys so crazy?
Why are you so crazy?
Why are you all so crazy?
Actually crazy.
I'm looking at you.
The guy above me is crazy.
Absolutely bonkers.
Thank you guys.
For all the...
the members and the donated members and the donors the Super Chats Thank you.
Thanks.
Oh my goodness gracious.
But yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for that.
Go Super!
Thank you.
This Super Chat is mint colored, right?
I'm color blind.
No!
Oh yes.
I really appreciate it.
I opened memberships yesterday.
I didn't even tell anyone.
And people found out somehow.
Which is so crazy.
But welcome to membership.
If you joined, thank you.
Or if you gifted.
If you gifted, thank you.
And if you were gifted, thank you for being here.
Anyway.
Of course there's no...
No pressure to donate.
As usual.
And no pressure to join.
Or anything like that.
And for anyone who says that it's too cheap.
Screw you!
For anyone who says raise the price.
No!
What's wrong with you?
You say what's wrong with me.
And I say what's wrong with you?
I ask.
What is wrong with you?
I mentioned it kind of before briefly.
I said that for memberships.
I planned on...
Making them a lower tier.
A lower price.
Because...
Since I have the podcast.
To be honest.
I won't be able to focus so much on like...
Membership content.
It kind of was like...
You'll get some membership streams.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you guys.
There will be some membership streams of course.
But...
It's like mostly for the emotes.
And...
And then once I get the Minecraft server set up.
That.
Yeah.
No pressure of course.
You guys are making me...
Feel like I need to do more.
Because you guys are...
Joining so fast.
And...
Gifting so many.
But yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the pinks.
Thank you.
Also I want to say...
A little bit today.
I don't know.
I have not been feeling so great lately.
Like just until...
Up until this stream.
My stomach was killing me again.
I think I am...
I am possessing some people that...
Are not...
Eating healthily.
So please think of your local ghost maid.
And eat well.
So that if I possess you...
You...
Don't hurt me in return.
You know?
I think part of it is stress though.
Just because I kind of came back from Japan.
And didn't...
Didn't have any time to rest.
When I came back home.
And...
And also...
I don't know...
Have you guys ever heard...
This is for all you cat owners out there.
If you weren't aware.
If you ever smell your cat.
And they smell a little bit sweet.
Then you are...
Kind of like a maple syrup.
It's like...
It could be like an actual medical condition.
And I smelled my cat's head.
And I was just like...
Why do you smell so sweet?
What did you get into?
And then I was like...
Uh oh.
And I remembered.
So tomorrow I have to call the vet.
And schedule a...
It could be diabetes.
Like feline diabetes.
Or it could be...
Like you know...
I looked it up.
Because I wasn't aware of the other things.
But it could be also...
A kidney thing.
Or a skin thing.
And he has been having some issues with his ears.
So I'm hoping it's the skin thing.
Because that would be the easiest thing.
To take care of.
But he's going to be okay.
Because I'm going to take him to the vet.
And we're going to get him all checked out.
But it does stress me out a little bit.
If he's good or not.
You know what I mean?
He's pregnant.
Oh my gosh.
I've always wanted...
Grand kittens.
Hoping for the best.
Thank you.
I don't mean to start the stream with such a...
Heavy topic.
Just letting you guys...
Letting you guys know...
Why I'm feeling a little...
In the brain.
You know?
My teeth.
Okay.
I'm going to...
No!
Okay.
Hold on.
No!
Okay.
I tested the game yesterday.
And it did this to me.
It is so bizarre.
When I'm clicking on this...
It's showing up...
In OBS.
Right?
It's showing up in OBS.
But on my actual screen...
It's not.
So I have to look at it...
Through OBS.
It's very strange.
How do I get out of this?
I'm actually going to pop out the screen.
Let me try that.
And...
Have it open three times.
Okay.
Wait.
That doesn't work.
Because I still have to...
Have it on this.
This is so weird.
I think it's because...
It's so old.
Subtitles on maybe?
Oh yes.
They will be on.
So weird.
Very weird.
Anyway.
The game must be haunted.
I know.
The cursor is so cursed.
I'm going to actually...
Sorry.
I'm going to make the notice...
A tiny bit smaller.
I think there's going to be a lot of them.
But thank you.
Okay.
For people that don't know this game.
It's old game.
I also don't know so much about it.
I've always seen...
Thank you for the 50.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I've always seen...
Like...
Screenshots from it.
But I'll be honest.
I've never...
I've never played it.
I've never tried this game before.
So it's kind of...
Reminds me of like The Negotiator.
It's old though.
It's old.
And I've also never watched anyone play it.
I just know that it's a little cursed.
And it's like...
It's like one of those games where you input your actions.
Or input what you say.
Before like AI was ever...
Like it has it's own in game AI.
You know?
Yeah.
OG AI chat bot.
This is a classic.
It is a classic.
Classic.
It's pretty cursed.
So...
We're gonna do our best to...
I don't know.
Got some mischief or something.
Probably fuck.
Sorry.
Have you guys seen that video of...
Miranda Cosgrove?
What's your favorite cuss word?
She goes...
Probably fuck.
Sorry.
Bleep that bleep that bleep that bleep that.
Probably bleep.
Sorry.
For saying such a bad word.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my.
Clutches pearls.
Anyway.
I'm so sorry.
It was the way that I...
It was the way that I said...
Cuss of mischief that made me think of it.
Okay?
Anyway.
You guys... You guys get me, right?
You guys understand me.
Right?
So do we name ourselves...
Melon?
Oh!
Wait.
I have to choose a name.
Oh they don't have mint.
Tammy?
Wait.
What would the closest to mint be?
Mark.
Mary.
Matt.
Mel.
Michael.
Thank you for that.
Thank you.
Oh my.
Nat.
Nick.
Nicole.
Oh my gosh.
There's so many names.
But they don't have mint.
Hmm.
Oh hi Mark.
David.
Let's see.
Let's go to the very top.
Meow.
Adam.
Al.
Hmm.
Andrew.
Oh my gosh.
I might say your name.
Isn't that kind of crazy?
Gon...
Gonzalo.
Gonzolo?
Ashley.
Oh.
Audrey.
Ben.
Am I... Am I... Did I say your name?
Raise your hand if I said your name.
Gonzalo.
Is that an actual one in here?
Is that a real name?
Genevra.
I've never heard of that name before either.
Um.
Espen.
Any Espens in the chat?
Aaron.
Eric.
Emily.
Ellen.
Elizabeth.
Ed.
Doug.
Diana.
Roll call.
Wisp roll call.
I'm Gonzalo.
Okay.
Since you're Gonzalo, we'll go with Gonzalo.
Wait.
What did they say?
Plissken?
That's so funny.
I thought, um.
When I tested this out.
I just picked Adam.
But I thought, uh.
Oh.
It does say, please choose a name.
Type the first letter.
Scroll with the arrow keys.
Press enter to begin.
It does say that entirely.
And I just, uh.
I thought maybe, um.
I could type in my name.
And I was like, will they say it?
Like, is there like an in-game voice thing?
Kind of like, you know.
Like some, uh.
What's the word?
Some gacha games.
You type in your name.
And it'll be like.
Mint.
Hello.
How are you?
Mint.
You know.
Gonzalo.
Oh my god.
Blue archive.
Yes.
Okay.
So let's, uh.
Let's look at the instructions.
Real quick.
Um.
Type to speak to the character at any time.
Move around with the arrow.
Look at this keyboard.
Sorry.
If I move off the screen.
It's because I have the other window open.
Like.
Type to speak to the characters at any time.
Move around with arrow keys.
Pick up and use objects with the mouse.
Actually.
I wonder if there's another way that I can.
Capture this.
I wonder if I do.
Window capture instead.
If it will allow me to see it.
Do you guys mind?
Sorry.
I totally should've.
I didn't think it would be an issue.
I should've totally done it.
Off stream.
I was like.
Oh maybe it's because I messed with something.
I was doing a couple setting things.
Go ahead.
Okay.
Thank you guys.
It's not gonna take long.
Let's see.
Window capture.
La la la la la.
La la la.
Oh wait.
This is.
Wait.
This is even.
Hold on.
This is.
See.
This is what I'm seeing.
When I click instructions.
Nothing.
This is.
Oh my gosh.
So it doesn't.
Okay.
Wait.
Hold on.
I'm gonna restart the game.
Oh.
Okay.
Let's restart.
Restart.
Okay.
Um.
It's okay because there's a little scene at the beginning too.
We can watch.
And the cursor's fixed.
Look at that.
I think it was good.
I'm gonna move it down.
There.
May take up to 60 seconds.
We are so back baby.
Yippee.
Oh.
They did say 60 seconds.
Hmm.
Hello.
Hey.
It's Tripp.
Oh my god.
Tripp.
Uh.
Geez.
It's been a long time since we got together.
Trying to blow out my eardrums.
But uh.
Uh.
Grace and I just thought it'd be.
It'd be.
It'd be really nice to see you tonight.
Tonight?
Oh.
Okay.
Yeah.
Uh.
How about 8 o'clock or something?
That'd be uh.
That'd be really nice.
Or 7.
Um.
Hope we can make it.
Oh yeah.
I will.
I'll be there.
It is so suspicious sounding.
It is so.
Suspicious sounding.
Whoa.
Facade.
Look our little happy.
Happy couple.
Question mark.
Hmm.
He's so awkward.
Maybe he's just shy.
I also struggle with talking on the phone.
Thank you guys for all the super chats.
Thank you.
And.
Let's see.
It works.
Okay.
There is no problem that I can't solve.
I'm a genius.
Okay.
Let's see the hints.
Oh wow.
This is a lot.
Okay.
Grace and Trip are in a desperate situation.
They need you.
You could influence them in several ways.
Exactly how.
Is up to you.
One approach is to try to help them.
To get them to work through their problems.
Or.
You could try to provoke and upset them.
Even be cruel.
If you want.
You can try to dig under the surface to expose the secrets they're hiding.
Sometimes it's necessary to talk fast and interrupt Grace and Trip.
To get a word in.
They tend to respond to agreement and disagreement.
Praise.
Criticism.
Flirtation.
References to relationship topics.
Such as divorce and...
Questions about their life.
Explanations and advice and so on.
As the tension builds.
They may try to force you to take sides.
Eventually they may seek your advice.
To get you to tell them what's wrong with them.
Depending on what you say or do.
Will determine if they stay together or not.
Facade needs to be replayed several times.
To experience the variation in the drama.
For more detailed hints...
Oh.
The mouse is...
Wait.
It looks good for you guys.
It is cursed for me.
You know what.
As long as it looks good for you guys.
Okay.
Let's turn the subtitles on.
Let's get going baby.
Let's go.
Oh my gosh.
I'm nervous.
What was it?
Was it Wasta to walk around?
I'm so small.
They're trapping me in.
Oh never mind.
Wait.
Why am I moving back and forth?
Give me a second.
Hello?
Fine.
Gonzalo!
Hey.
I thought I heard someone out here.
Great to see you.
It's been a while.
How's it going?
Wait.
Hold on.
How do I move?
Oh.
Here we go.
Well.
Come on in.
Hello.
Don't move.
Let me go get Grace.
Okay.
I'm gonna come in.
No.
Here we are.
Gonzalo.
Hi.
How are you?
Oh god.
It's been such a long time.
Hi.
Yeah.
How are you doing?
I just asked him that.
I'm great.
Oh.
By the way.
You look fabulous.
Oh.
You too, babe.
So come on in.
Make yourself at home.
Gonzalo.
That's such a...
That's an interesting way to say hello.
You're such a kidder.
Gonzalo.
Let me get you a drink.
Oh.
I'll get it.
No.
We have a guest.
We can let the answering machine pick it up.
Macchiato, please.
What?
Wait.
Let's just wait for the answering machine.
I'll pick up.
Oh.
Hmm.
Gonzalo.
Oh.
No.
Who is this?
Grace?
Is that you?
Oh.
That's my dad.
I can hear his voice.
Oh.
Dad?
Okay.
He's being annoying as usual.
Dad?
Are you alive?
I've... I've missed you.
Dad!
Grace's parents.
They're something else.
Really classy people.
No.
They're impossible.
They're always expecting me to act like the dutiful daughter.
It's so annoying.
This is so beautiful.
Oh.
I can't look up.
Well.
It didn't take long for you two to bond or whatever.
Aren't we friends?
Hey.
Gonzalo.
Seeing you brings back good memories.
You know?
Why is everyone talking over each other?
It's so chaos.
Whoa.
I just realized something.
What?
Uh.
Well.
Tonight is special.
Gonzalo.
Remember?
It was almost exactly ten years ago tonight that you introduced us.
Senior year of college.
Oh.
Geez.
Remember that?
I remember.
We really want to thank you for years and years of...
Pain.
Agony.
Haunting.
Love.
Why do they look at each other like that?
I mean.
It's...
It's a great day to be here tonight.
What are you... What is that?
Oh.
That.
That's just a little joke advice giver toy thing that I like to consult every now and then.
What?
When I need a little guidance.
His mother gave that to him.
Aww.
I'm gonna fix us some drinks.
Well.
We should drink.
We should have something fun.
Like sangria.
Sangria?
Everybody tells me I fix the best drinks.
So I'm sure you're gonna love this.
Now Tripp.
Don't get too worked up with the drinks tonight.
I'm gonna puke.
No.
Tripp.
Don't pressure our friend.
Okay?
No.
Maybe you'd like some juice or mineral water.
Oh.
Come on.
No.
Oh.
I'll take a hot one.
Good.
Okay.
Alright.
Fine.
This reminds me of the time we had your book group friends over.
Grace.
I know what you want.
But I'll ask anyway.
What would you like to drink?
I'm going to join our friend in what he is having.
Ooh.
Girl feeling spicy.
Well.
I uh.
I know what you want Grace.
So.
Gonzalo.
I'm hoping you can help me understand where I went wrong with my new decorating.
Your decorating is beautiful.
Alright Grace.
Yours is ready.
Thanks.
See.
I told you he would like it.
Yeah.
There's nothing wrong with it.
That's what I said.
So.
About my decorating.
That's what I.
You know when I look at this wedding picture hanging here in this room.
Do you have anime figures?
Yeah.
Oh god.
It's impressive.
Even after a full day's work designing magazine ads.
Grace somehow finds the time to decorate.
Haha.
I guess it's just the artist in me dying to get out.
This is yours.
Oh.
That's good.
So about this wedding picture here.
It obviously just does not go anymore.
What?
What do you mean?
I mean with my new decorating and all.
Oh Grace.
Whoa.
It's like distorting.
I think it's melting.
Ah yes.
I've been waiting for someone.
Oh but I liked what you said about my decorating.
Besides I'm redoing it all this week.
What do you mean?
You've been waiting for someone to say that.
Well.
You and I are getting along better tonight than I first thought.
Aren't we friends?
Like I'm confused.
Oh god.
Oh.
Thanks.
Oh that's nice Grace.
Our friend seems happy to see you again after so long.
What?
Uh oh.
The music's getting kind of crazy.
Tripp have you noticed we're fighting in front of our friend?
Grace.
Come on.
That kind of statement is not helpful.
Tripp there's nothing wrong with disagreeing.
In front of our friend.
We're not disagreeing.
Shut up.
That's...
Whoa.
Are you sick?
Why are you coughing?
Why are they so offended?
What did you...
He's...
Melon.
You're being...
Okay.
Gonzalo.
I think this evening is over.
You've gotta leave.
Oh no!
We'll be fine.
You should just go.
No!
I'm sorry Tripp.
I didn't mean it.
For some reason Melon just makes them like kick you out.
View your generated stage play.
Oh.
Cancel.
It like...
opened up its own document.
That's so funny.
Wow guys.
How we get a good feel about that one.
I don't know what...
Melon.
Gonzalo get out of here.
Get out of here.
How we feel about that?
How we feeling?
I think...
I don't...
You need to leave.
Okay.
Replay.
Back to main menu.
To replay, please exit and...
No way.
What?
I have to exit and...
I have to relaunch it every time.
No way!
Aww.
Oh, an electronic tip jar.
That's so cute.
Okay.
Let's try... Oh my gosh.
We have 26 seconds every time for it to load.
It has to 60 second generate a new scenario.
I guess that makes sense, right?
Okay.
This next time...
This next time, I think I'm going to genuinely try, okay?
You should say ectoplasm to them.
Not enough kept you waiting, huh?
We're gonna...
Also, I am seeing that there are Streamlabs donos.
I think they're totally backlogged by the members, but I am seeing you guys.
Thank you.
Get melloned, bozo.
Hey!
It's Tripp.
Hey, Tripp.
Uh...
I guess it's been quite some time since we last saw you.
Uh, but uh...
Grace and I thought it'd be great if you came over tonight.
Speak to them in Metal Gear Solid quotes.
We could try that too.
We have many...
We have every scenario we'd ever want to do.
So good!
You could just combine around 8 or something.
Can I skip this?
Okay.
I think I can.
I think I just did.
Or, I broke the game.
Never mind.
Look at our happy couple!
Yeah!
Grace!
Yeah, Tripp!
I thought that was like her boyfriend or something that called.
I was really scared for them.
I... I was scared.
Like, what if she's been seeing another man?
Oh my gosh.
No.
How do I get to Gonzalo again?
I like when they say, Gonzalo!
Melon.
Alright, here we go.
Round 2.
I wonder if you can talk to the phone.
I tried!
I tried saying hello to my dad.
Tripp, when are you going to get rid of this?
Oh.
Oh, sorry.
I for some reason think that you...
I know, I know.
I'll do it right now, alright?
Oh, he's here!
I'm here!
You said he's coming an hour from now.
No, he's right on time.
Tripp!
Hello?
Open up!
Oh!
Gonzalo!
Tripp!
I'm so happy you could make it!
Oh, me too!
Kisses!
Well, come on in.
Okay!
Uh, I'll uh, I'll go get Grace.
Grace, where are you?
No, no, here we are!
What's in here?
Gonzalo?
Yes.
Hi, how are you?
I am so happy to see you after so long!
Yeah, how are you doing?
Sorry, I went to Europe.
Well...
That's where I learned how to kiss.
I learned how to kiss.
Um...
Well, come in.
Make yourself at home.
Oh, close the door.
Yeah, you should do that.
We took a photo from our trip to Italy a couple of weeks ago.
Oh!
Italy.
Oh, sorry.
Well, um, come look at this Italy photo.
Gonzalo?
Italy.
Oh, you'll never guess where I took that picture.
Is this really something you want to brag about, Tripp?
Why not?
I'll tell you about it in a sec.
Tell me.
Yeah, yeah, I've got to tell you about Italy.
Yes.
Tripp, we don't want to depress our guest.
Damn it, Grace.
Would it kill you to be positive for once?
Shut up, Grace.
Italy!
That's, um...
Gonzalo.
Tell me about Italy.
You had me going there for a sec.
Tell me.
You were afraid to push your luck.
Mess with us.
You're crazy, you know that?
This is going well.
Anyway, what were we talking about?
Italy.
I think I've said Italy five times now.
Please.
So, about my decorating.
What?
We were not talking about that!
You know, I've been collecting these little glass sculptures for a long time now.
Everybody always comments on Grace's sculptures.
But now when I look at them...
They give me such a headache.
I prefer anime.
Ah, yes.
I've been waiting for someone to say that.
What are you talking about?
Tripp, he is just being honest about my decorating.
Which I appreciate.
I am being honest.
But I still think this looks fine.
No.
Well, you two are all chummy already.
That's good.
Hmm.
Gonzalo, seeing you brings back wonderful memories.
What does that sound?
Wow.
Oh, he grabbed his little magic 8-ball.
I just realized something.
What?
Well, actually, tonight's a special night.
We should celebrate, in fact.
What do you mean?
Gonzalo, remember it was almost exactly 10 years ago tonight that you introduced us?
Oh, I can hug him!
You're hugging me.
That's kind of you.
I'm sure Tripp's happy to...
Oh, you're hugging me.
Oh, that's nice, Grace.
Our friend seems to be...
Oh.
Oh, wow.
You seem to remember how much Tripp loves getting attention.
I can't kiss him!
Uh...
I'm not gonna let go.
Keep going.
All right.
Gonzalo, that's it.
No!
I thought you were down to clown Tripp!
Don't look at me like that!
While you kick me out!
No, I have to restart the game again!
Please!
No!
Tripp!
He...
He felt something, you know?
And so he felt that maybe if he didn't kick me out, something new would start.
After this, he has like a little musical theater moment.
He's just like...
I never knew that you saw me like that.
But from this moment I can't stop thinking about the touch of your lips upon mine.
The kiss button was too strong.
I had no idea it was there!
The comfort or the hug.
I kept cutting them off.
Okay.
We're gonna be serious.
We're serious.
I don't even know how...
These guys like hate each other.
How are we supposed...
I'm not supposed to be in the middle of this.
Hey!
It's Tripp!
Tripp!
Hey, it's been a while.
Yeah, you sure are trippin' tonight, mister.
Grace and I just... I'm just gonna skip it.
Be the bigger threat.
Absolutely.
Also, let me know if like I have to turn up the game volume so you can hear them while I'm playing, cause I turn it down for his little voicemail.
It's so loud.
You know what?
I'm just gonna go with Adam.
Let's just get into it.
I'm literally crying from laughing so hard.
I keep doing this.
I'm here!
Hello!
Open the door!
It's Mint!
Hi!
Adam!
Tripp!
It's been so long since we've seen you!
Oh, I don't like him calling me Adam.
How you doing, man?
I'm good.
I'm great.
Great!
Yeah.
Wow.
It's really, really great to see you.
Well, come on in.
He likes me.
Ojamashimasu.
I'll look at Grace.
What can I do?
Does this have to happen?
Are you talking to me?
I don't think you'd do anything that would challenge your identity.
Come on.
Are you talking to me?
Anything that would challenge your identity.
Just make me go and try to enjoy myself.
Oh!
Adam.
Hi!
How are you?
I am so happy to see you after so long.
Hi, Grace.
That's funny.
I said the same thing.
Hi, Grace.
And I've got to say, you look really good.
You too.
Well, come on in.
Make yourself...
What did I say wrong?
I'm going to fix us some drinks.
Ah, you need to help me break in my expensive new set of cocktail making accessories.
We should have something fun.
Like sangria.
Everybody tells me I fix the best drinks, so I'm sure you're going to love this.
We love sangria.
Now, Tripp, don't get too worked up with the drinks.
Perfect.
No, no.
Maybe you'd like some juice or mineral water.
Thank you.
Um, I'll take a hot spicy drink.
Okay, look.
I'm just going to open up a bottle of Merlot and make everybody happy.
Adam, trust me, it's good stuff.
Yes, you don't need to push the fancy drinks tonight.
Oh, I took it first.
Grace, I assume you want your usual or lovely very cold glass of Chardonnay?
He can't use it now.
I took it.
The Merlot sounds fine.
Sure thing.
I took it first.
I doubt it.
Ew.
Sure thing.
Why not?
Who knows?
Yes.
Alright, guys.
Ask me a question about your future.
And I will ask the Magic 8 Ball for its grand wise advice.
Not advice.
It's true.
This is what will happen.
Pizza tomorrow?
I doubt it.
But it's Friday.
No.
Is Trip a murderer?
Maybe later.
It depends on how well we do here.
Will I finally find love?
First Perhaps soon.
Oh my gosh.
The stakes are high.
Is Grace evil?
No.
Okay.
Trip or Grace?
It can't be that.
It has to be a yes or no question.
The conch has spoken.
Can love bloom on the battlefield?
Who knows?
I love this thing.
You're a little close to me, Grace.
How's the weather?
I'll ask the 8 Ball.
Is the weather good?
Perhaps soon.
How do I put this down?
Oh, dang it.
I did it again.
What's he doing?
Oh, well.
Thanks.
Adam, you're always so sweet.
Grace, I'm giving you the first glass.
Why did you cut her off like that?
Nope.
That glass is mine.
Adam, I was going...
Oh, I'll get it.
Sippy, sippy.
We can let the answering machine get it.
You know what?
I'm just going to put this in the bathroom.
How did you walk in front of us?
Sippy, sippy.
I'm drunk.
Oh, yeah, you know.
I think I'll fix you a real drink in not too long.
Anyhow.
Hey, you've reached the fabulous...
Oh, my God.
Everyone is talking.
Please.
Travis, are you there?
It's your mother.
I haven't heard from you and Grace in a while.
Take a look at this photo I just put up from our trip to Italy.
I'm just calling to find out if you're settled in in your new apartment.
That's all.
Adam, come over here and sit on my couch with me.
Can you call if you're not traveling?
I know you're traveling a lot these days.
Everyone is talking!
Who is Travis?
Oh, Tripp, don't put our friend on the spot like that.
Well, actually, this trip to Italy was meant to be our second honeymoon.
Tripp, don't exaggerate.
It was simply a weekend getaway.
So, in a word, this says...
It says...
Love.
It says love.
Oh.
Or not.
He doesn't believe.
I don't know.
Travis is Tripp's full name.
Oh.
Romance!
It says romance.
Of course!
Yeah.
Oh.
Never mind.
What?
That's what you said!
Could be.
Good one.
Yeah.
Why am I the awkward one here?
Uh...
Adam.
Maybe you didn't come here to hear this.
What?
Uh-oh.
Tripp, there's nothing wrong with disagreeing in front of our friend.
Disagreeing?
We're not disagreeing.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
We're not.
No.
Everything...
Everything is good.
What?
You know, ever since we got married, Tripp is forever trying to get me to buy new furniture and redecorate.
Everything is not good.
Everything is...
And it's true.
I kind of enjoy it, but...
Oh, yeah.
It's great.
Everybody loves it when they come in and see our latest decoration scheme.
But... Adam.
Yes?
You have to look at this room and admit it looks terrible.
It looks great!
I mean, look around.
This room is... it's hideous.
Ah, yeah.
It looks great!
Adam, I knew you'd like it.
Yeah!
See, Grace?
You don't realize how good all this looks.
It's a little empty.
Could've used some more wall scrolls or something.
And how good you look.
So, about my decorating.
You know, at work I waste all day designing ads for apartments like this.
Uh-huh.
And it makes me think, I want this style for my apartment.
Yeah?
This style makes me feel like I'm inside one of your ads.
It's great.
Oh, I'm sitting.
But, damn it, I'm wrong.
It's just not coming together at all.
That's okay.
Not coming together?
What?
What's going on?
Why is she so angry?
Really?
Oh.
You're hugging me.
It's good to see you two bonding again.
I'm comforting you.
Well, you're really affectionate tonight, aren't you?
I'm drunk.
She's a villain.
I can return most of this and start over again on this room.
Are you okay?
I love this...
No, I can't say love or else they'll say I'm...
They think I'm loving...
The room looks great.
What?
Aha.
I knew it.
I was right, Grace.
You're the only one unhappy with your decorating.
No.
Decorating is not...
It's not...
Not...
Grace, come on.
You're so good at it.
You're so good.
Oh my god, we're helping you guys.
I think we're actually helping.
Ugh, you are impossible.
Or not.
I'm never happy.
Tripp, our whole marriage is so...
I don't think we're helping.
What?
He's not doing anything.
What's wrong, Grace?
What's wrong?
Adam, I...
And you...
I can predict what you'll say.
Me?
You're so positive tonight.
It's driving me crazy.
Um...
Uh, what should I say, you guys?
More real.
I like my fancy drinks, okay?
Oh my god.
What should I say?
I like the good things in life.
Does that make me a bad person?
They're just drinks!
Goddamn second honeymoon.
You never call me when you're on business trips.
You never call me, you know that?
Um, um, what do I say?
Something positive?
Okay, you know what?
I'll take another drink.
I need to ask you something.
Grace, Tripp, let me ask our guest a question.
Never mind, they ignored me.
Adam.
Yes.
Yes or no?
In a marriage, shouldn't you try to help the other person get what they want?
What?
I mean, marriage is supposed to be about what the other person wants, not what you want, right?
Yes or no?
Um...
Uh...
Yes.
Let's just agree with her.
Why are you upset?
Oh, yeah.
That's fine.
You should both...
I tried so hard to reach out to you, Grace.
You reject me.
You're cold.
You're distant.
It's killing me.
You're tearing me apart, Lisa.
Go away.
I don't want to look at you.
Damn it, Tripp.
Are we still doing...
BBQ?
What are you saying?
What?
Grace, what the hell are you saying about me in there?
Wait, I'm in here.
I'm sorry.
This is a disaster.
No, no.
I'm having fun.
Please.
Adam, from what you said before about saying yes, I think we've already learned something about Grace.
Oh.
We're talking about me again, are we?
She's getting the gun.
There's no gun.
We don't have to do this.
Things are okay.
I can't stand the pretending anymore.
I can't take it.
Get away from the window, Grace.
Okay.
Sorry.
I think this evening is over.
You've got to leave.
No!
I was helping!
Just go.
No!
What did I do?
Oh, man.
They are so...
We were helping!
What's wrong with being a little positive?
Is there actually a good ending?
I have no idea.
The fact that each scenario is different too is crazy.
My drink.
Hey, at least we finished our drink, right?
I think I should be like a hostage negotiator.
I think, actually, maybe this game will train you for hostage negotiation situations.
Because only the bad outcomes happen.
And so it trains you to not say those things.
Mhm.
What if I say Okay.
I'm gonna go in with this approach.
I'm gonna say, I just got a new job as a man.
I'm a marriage counsellor.
Then they feel safe.
Trauma dumping on me.
And then I say I charge $150 an hour.
Then I also get paid for it.
Stonks.
Mint as a hostage negotiator.
So, it'll be great.
Oh, sorry.
I forgot.
I can skip this part.
A guy got the good ending and completed the game by being rude and not giving a crap the entire time first try?
No way.
Okay.
I can be a jerk.
I can't... well, you have to be like the right level of jerk.
Because if you're just like, shut up Grace.
What if I don't say anything the entire time?
What if I like...
What if I just...
What if I just stand there?
What if I don't say anything?
Let's try it.
Sorry that the subtitles seem a little bit like, inconsistent, but...
That's the best we can do.
Oh, gosh.
I did it again.
Wah!
I'm here!
Open the door.
Gonzalo!
Hey!
Tripp!
I thought I heard someone out here.
Great to see...
Oh.
Well, come on in.
Wait.
What happened?
It'll be just a sec while I go get Grace.
Tripp, I'm stuck in the door!
Tripp!
Tripp, I... Oh, okay.
Nevermind.
I was gonna say, Tripp, I can't come in.
Let us sit down.
Put on a happy face.
I don't understand why you're always doing this to me.
Grace, we do this later...
Can I make a little phone call real quick?
I'm ready.
You just...
No new messages.
Oh!
I didn't do anything.
Gonzalo?
Hi!
How are you?
Oh, it's so nice to see you.
It feels like it's been forever.
Yeah!
Yeah, it has been a long time.
Hide the ball?
So true.
Oh, I'm... there.
Well, come on in.
Make yourself at home.
Oh, that!
That's just a little joke advice giver toy thing that I like to consult every now and then.
Let's put it in the kitchen.
When I need a little guidance.
His mother gave that to him.
Stocking stuffer.
Oh.
Well...
If I can.
So, make yourself at home.
I am!
I'm taking your stuff.
Oh, close the door.
Oh, good, good.
Oh!
Gonzalo!
Yeah!
Take a look at this photo I just put up from our trip to Italy.
Wow, we're already getting into it.
Little solid.
Gonzalo!
Yeah!
Come here.
I want you to...
Gonzalo.
Come over here and sit on the couch with me.
Oh, they're making me choose.
No, hold on.
Now.
Actually, I'm gonna go sit on the couch with him.
Trip darling, your obsession with that photo is making our friend uncomfortable.
I'm very uncomfortable.
Romance.
It says romance.
Where?
I'm gonna fix us some drinks.
Oh, and I've got these fancy new cocktail shakers.
No!
He got it!
That was a martini sound.
I'm a real expert at fixing these.
At least that's what everyone tells me.
Uh-huh.
Trip, let's not go crazy with the drinks, okay?
Yeah.
It says Italy.
Italy.
It's a... it's really... it's really...
Well, you know what?
I'm just gonna make you a martini.
No, no, Gonzalo.
Maybe you'd like some juice or mineral water.
You know, I'm just gonna open up a bottle of Merlot or something.
I just want us to be relaxed and enjoy ourselves tonight.
I'm not saying anything, you guys.
Yeah.
Yes.
Sometimes a simple glass of wine is better than those fancy drinks you always insist on making.
This one looks like a Yu-Gi-Oh!
character, right?
What do you say, Grace?
I know it's not true.
This one right here.
Oh, do you like those sculptures?
Oh, uh-oh.
I used to be so into collecting them.
Into them?
You love your sculptures so much, I'm not even allowed to touch them.
Trip, your poker buddies used them as ashtrays.
What?
Anyhow, Gonzalo...
What do you mean, anyhow?
Trip!
He says, no, I'm not.
As for my drink...
Yeah, it does look like the...
Yeah, the harpy.
Um, I'll have a glass of Merlot, too.
Oh.
Good.
Okay.
Big sigh.
Oh, God.
Why are we big sigh...
Gonzalo.
Yes?
I hope you didn't come here tonight to be entertained.
What?
Here, Grace.
I poured you the first glass.
Okay, thanks.
Anyway...
Oh, she just walked through the...
Grace, come on.
That kind of statement is not helpful.
Trip, there's nothing wrong with disagreeing in front of our friends.
Disagree?
We're not.
They're talking over each other again.
Sheesh.
Well...
You two are all chummy already.
That's...
That's good.
You know, ever since we got married, I can't help it.
I'm forever buying new furniture and redecorating.
They're just going off on their own.
I don't need to do anything.
It's in your blood.
You grew up with this stuff.
Sheesh.
Here you are.
So, I normally like redecorating, Gonzalo.
Now, be honest with me.
Agree that this room just does not work.
He's going to kick you out.
Come on.
What are you talking about?
I'm not saying anything.
Well, I'll just put this on the bar for you.
Thank you.
So, about my decorating?
All day at work, I design ads for decorative objects.
Like these sculptures.
Right.
Sculptures.
And then I think I want to design them into my apartment.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Everybody always says how much they love Grace's sculptures.
But...
Gonzalo, you've not said a single word for a while now.
Are you alright?
They've noticed.
Just...
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Just watch.
Oh, good.
Oh.
I'm sure I can return most of this and try to start over again on this room.
Grace, everything's fine.
No one is complaining about your decorating.
No.
He is just being courteous.
This room is not...
Grace, come on.
People like it.
You're the only one...
You know, Tripp, if you hadn't convinced me to go into advertising, I could have painted that painting on the wall instead of buying it.
Oh, my God.
This is so...
They are...
Never happy.
Oh.
You're driving me insane.
You're goddamn decorating.
You're both insufferable.
You're never satisfied with anything.
Huh?
What?
What was that?
Gonzalo, can you believe this?
Oh, I cannot.
I cannot believe this.
Gonzalo.
Uh...
Can you...
Can you just...
Goddamn manipulation.
Manipulation Station.
Grace, I just wanna be alone.
I just wanna be alone.
I'm stuck, Grace.
Can you see that?
Can we just do that?
I'm stuck.
Here, I'm gonna also not face him.
Alright.
You know what?
Gonzalo, I need to ask you something.
Okay.
Yeah.
Grace, let me ask our guest a question.
Okay.
Ask away.
Gonzalo, yes or no?
Oh.
If one person in a marriage gives the other advice, and that advice is taken, years later, can you be blamed for that?
Oh my god.
What?
Is it okay to get blamed for giving advice that was taken, like, ten years ago?
Yes or no?
Um, yeah, let's check the eight ball.
Could be.
Look, don't bother answering.
I don't need to hear it.
Okay, nevermind.
It was too late.
I keep trying to help you, Grace, but you reject me.
Oh my god.
You're tearing me apart.
You cut me off.
You cut me out of your life.
God damn it!
Oh my god, he's so loud.
Ugh, yeah, good.
Get away from me.
I don't want to look at you.
I'm gonna comfort her.
Damn it, Tripp!
Oh, nevermind.
Come here, come here, come here.
I don't want to kiss you on accident.
No, wait, please.
What?
Are you talking about me?
I'm not talking to you.
Gonzalo...
I can't believe you have to see this.
Um, me neither.
Gonzalo, in what you said before about marriage, I think that tells us something about Tripp.
So true.
Oh, we're talking about me, are we?
What?
Oh, he's back!
Grace, we don't... we don't have to do this.
Things are okay.
We can just...
Gonzalo.
I can't stand the pretending anymore.
I can't take it.
Me neither.
No, Grace, we can... I mean, come on.
Don't make it out to be so bad.
She's so angry!
Ugh.
I'm on Grace's side right now.
What is it?
Is there something about me?
Um...
Look, why don't we talk about us?
Our relationship.
Hmm.
It's so annoying.
Grace, why is it that any time I want to do something nice for you, you resist it?
Tripp...
Like I always have to convince you.
Gonzalo, you know...
Oh, no.
I can't drink it.
Ugh.
Oh, I can!
And drink all his... wine.
Yeah?
Well, you were...
All this stuff...
You were in the middle of a sentence there.
Having all this money makes us so happy.
We're so happy, aren't we, Tripp?
Jesus, what do you want?
Now you're unhappy because we're...
Ugh, that brass bowl.
It's just so infuriating.
What's wrong with the bowl?
Watch how you put that goddamn gift on display in our own living room.
Who... who gifted this?
God, Gonzalo.
I'm getting really tired of talking about Tripp's stuff.
Oh, sorry.
Um, let's talk about anime.
Ah.
Gonzalo?
Yeah?
You're saying I don't communicate?
Wait, that's not... Komi-san doesn't communicate?
I reach out to Grace.
Is this your favorite anime?
I really do.
I try to be open and honest, you know?
Gonzalo.
Stop.
Oh, my God.
What if...
Uh... uh... communication sucks.
No, communication... communication.
See, Grace?
I feel like it's you that's not reaching out.
Ugh.
Um... you... you both are bad at talking.
Aha!
Gonzalo, you're saying I'm communicative?
You know, Tripp, whenever I really try to talk honestly about things, you don't want to hear it.
No, I said you're both bad about it.
What?
Gonzalo, I think I'm the only one who is trying to be the most honest here.
Gonzalo.
Duh.
Um, be honest about your feeling.
Yes?
Look, you're doing it again.
You're putting this all on me.
I can't.
I'm just trying to help you.
Can I help you, man?
Gonzalo?
Yes?
If there's something about me, just tell me what it is.
Um, let's see.
Let's keep talking about Grace.
Gonzalo, look around this apartment.
It's got everything anyone would ever want.
But Grace?
Oh no, she's never satisfied.
Tripp, ugh.
I'm so sick of this.
You complain too much.
I don't think...
Well, I mean... we've got everything.
Tripp, you just don't... ugh.
You don't have love.
Ah.
What the hell are you talking about?
That makes no sense.
Okay.
Gonzalo.
Yes?
If there's something about me, just tell me what it is.
You're... annoying.
Aha.
Gonzalo, you're saying I'm angry?
No, I said...
It makes me so angry.
Angry?
What?
Gonzalo, did I ever tell you how she humiliated me at a gallery in front of her artist friends?
What did you do?
What did she do?
What?
Tripp, whatever I really said, I'm sure you deserved it.
Ugh.
What?
Hold on.
Let's keep our focus on Tripp.
No.
Tripp, it's your fault.
Ten years ago, freshly married and just out of college, you convinced me to go into advertising instead of art.
What?
If it weren't for you, I could be a real artist by now.
She's blaming him?
That was your decision.
Gonzalo.
Ugh.
That... that was your decision, Grace.
That's bullshit.
Oh.
Ugh.
No, I'm on your side.
No, we need... we need to talk about us both, not just one.
What makes me the most angry, Tripp, is what you took away from me.
What?
I wasted ten years in this marriage...
You can still be an artist.
Making advertising...
What's wrong with advertising?
See...
Gonzalo.
All this time, I just can't stop thinking that I should have been painting.
Why don't you just do it then?
That's what I'm saying.
Just...
Be a goddamn artist already.
Just do it.
Yes?
Ah, yes.
Just you saying that should really help her.
Well, if I could be a painter, I... I would.
Look, let's not focus on just me or you.
Let's talk about us.
Oh my god, I think we're actually getting somewhere here, you guys.
You just pretend to like all this stuff.
Fancy cigars and fine wine.
You think I'm not good enough.
I never said that.
I'm saying there's more to you than all this.
All?
What else is there?
What?
Than...
Gonzalo.
Thank you.
That helps us.
It does?
Tripp, I know that you like to hang out at that little sports bar on the corner.
What?
Not...
No.
Why did he...
Tripp, it's all right.
The way he moved closer.
The sports bar.
Why?
Oh god.
This is so frigging insane.
I love sports.
Ugh, you...
Does anyone...
Um...
Okay, that's it.
No more of this bullshit.
Gonzalo, I know what you're hinting at.
About us.
Oh, no.
What?
About our lifestyle.
Do you two want the truth?
Huh?
Okay.
Give us the truth.
Gonzalo, I know what you're hinting at.
Listen.
Do you want to hear it?
Yes.
Grace?
See, Gonzalo, I've been paying attention to what you've been saying tonight.
Okay.
You've been really pushing me tonight.
I'm a pusher.
It makes me wonder if you're really my friend or not.
Tripp?
Gonzalo?
Quit interrupting me.
Let me finish.
Gonzalo, come on.
Yes or no?
Do you really think that saying that Grace is communicative, telling me I'm not communicative, telling Grace to make art, that will somehow realize something about our marriage?
Yes.
Is all of that arguing intended to mean something?
Right.
Yes.
Realize.
Grace.
Realize your power.
See, I'm ashamed of my parents.
Where is this coming from?
What?
Your parents are great.
I love seeing them.
I know.
But yours, they're so ignorant.
But they're real.
I hate how my parents are pretending to be something.
I've tried hard to be like your family.
Tripp, really?
What?
I don't...
But I feel like a phony.
Phony.
I feel like I can never get rid of my past.
What's your past?
What happened?
It's kind of like I don't know who I am anymore.
What are you talking about?
This guy needs therapy.
Oh.
Let's go.
Oh my God.
Drop a melon.
I'm going to give you the truth too, Tripp.
See, they're being honest with each other.
I painted this.
Yes.
Bullshit.
I am an artist, Tripp.
Fuck you.
It's beautiful.
You've been secretly painting?
What's wrong with...
Every time you go on a goddamn business trip, I paint.
What's wrong with painting?
So don't ever give me any more of your...
You could never be an artist.
Crap.
What's wrong with art?
Why?
It's MSP.
It's so...
Oh, I'm sitting again.
I'm up again.
Jesus.
Okay.
Gonzalo.
Grace, I have one more thing to say.
Again?
What?
Grace.
I know you want to be an artist.
Yes.
But...
Gonzalo.
I have one more thing to say.
You could never be married to you if you were.
What?
Why not?
I can't.
I just can't.
But Tripp...
When I married you, see, I was sure I could convince you to give it up.
To go into advertising.
What's so special about advertising?
And I did it.
And it worked.
But now...
I don't know, Grace.
What is wrong with Tripp?
I don't know.
Why do you hate art?
Tripp, what is wrong with you?
Oh, my God.
That's how I feel.
This changes everything.
Yeah.
Are you...
You...
You really have to be an artist.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
You finally admitted it.
You just don't want me to be an artist.
Why?
You're so...
What?
You...
You think I'm a phony for despising my upbringing.
What is your upbringing?
But...
But at least you had a real upbringing.
It's me who had a fake one.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm gonna comfort.
Gonzalo.
Oh, my God.
Yes.
Look.
We need to talk.
Yeah.
I'm here for you.
Gonzalo.
Thanks for coming over.
You...
I think you helped us.
And no.
Gonzalo.
Yeah.
You don't need to say anything more.
More.
Say...
Anything more.
Are they leaving?
This is your house.
Gonzalo.
Yeah?
Please.
It's okay.
Can I get another drink?
I...
I didn't eat today.
Please.
I...
I thought...
I thought we were having dinner...
I'm taking the magic 8-ball.
Will I starve tonight?
Bye.
No!
Oh, thank god.
Wait, what did she say?
Oh!
What just happened?
Did I win?
You moved in with them.
She said, bye, thanks.
Oh!
Yippee!
What?
It's my house now?
Oh my god, this is actually like what happens to me for real.
I go and haunt someone and then sometimes they leave.
And it becomes my house.
That's really exciting.
I didn't know that that...
could happen in the game as well.
Hold on, let's try another one.
I think someone said, like, speak only...
That one, we barely talked and it actually ended up working out.
How is that possible?
Maybe they really just needed to talk things out and we were just a good friend to listen.
You know?
You can... I want to actually...
I do want to kind of romance someone.
You know?
Let's kind of...
Who should we romance?
Tripp or Grace?
Tripp is kind of crazy.
Tripp is...
I don't understand what his deal is.
Why does he hate art so much?
Why does he not want her to be a painter?
Why can't she just do that?
Like, as a hobby even.
Grace?
Okay.
We're gonna romance Grace.
Alright, here we go.
She has to advertise.
Why he is so, like...
Oh my god, I'm gonna ask her if she painted that.
Only MGS quotes, right?
Okay, let's do that one and then we'll romance Grace.
Okay.
She's gonna really fall hard for Gonzalo.
Alright, first we'll do the Metal Gear.
And then...
Where are the new wine glasses?
What for?
Oh my gosh, I do that every time.
That should be obvious.
Oh god, Tripp, don't turn this into a big production, please.
Oh, he's here.
I'm here.
You said he's coming an hour from now.
Oh, he's supposed to be here now.
I'm here.
Gonzalo!
Oh my god.
God, it's been so long since I've seen you.
Kept you waiting.
How you doing, man?
Wait, what titty?
Waiting, huh?
Well, come on in.
Uh, what else should I say?
Uh, it'll be just a sec while I go get Grace.
Okay.
Oh wait, um...
No, no, here we are.
Gonzalo?
Yes?
Hi, how are you?
I am so happy to see you after so long.
Yeah, how are you?
Um...
Well, come in.
Make yourself at home.
Oh, Gonzalo?
That's so nice of you to say.
By the way, you look fabulous.
Hey, Gonzalo.
Seeing you.
Oh, I'll get it.
No, no, we have a guest.
We can let the answering machine pick it up.
Grace?
Why did she turn?
It's so scary.
Don't be rude.
It's probably just the cleaning service cancelling on us again.
Grace?
Hello?
No, please don't.
Please don't do that.
Who is this, Grace?
Is that you?
Is this for you?
Oh, it's my dad.
I can hear his voice.
Here you go.
Oh.
Oh!
Excuse me.
I must have the wrong number.
Okay, he's being annoying as usual.
Just, just hang it up.
She didn't care.
Oh, good.
You hung up.
I can call him back later.
Or, you know, she did.
She didn't notice.
Wait.
Uh...
Oh.
You, uh...
Wait, I think they just noticed.
Oh, well.
Uh, sorry.
Sorry.
Gonzalo.
You maniac.
You sex maniac.
Never afraid to mess with us.
You're a beautiful couple.
You're crazy.
You know that.
I'm crazy.
Anyway, what were we talking about?
Hey.
Gonzalo.
Yeah.
Seeing you again makes me remember the good times we all used to have.
Oh, yeah.
Yes.
Those crazy parties.
Yeah.
I've, um...
I've missed you.
Hey.
I've missed you, too.
I just realized something.
What?
Oh.
Yeah.
Gonzalo.
Careful.
Too many compliments can go to Tripp's head.
I...
I'll...
I'll compliment you, too, Grace.
So, yeah.
Uh, well.
Remember how you...
Sorry.
I gave up the Metal Gear Quote thing.
I couldn't think of anything to say.
Wait.
What did he say?
Uh...
What did he ask?
Um...
Well, without you, we wouldn't even have this celebration.
Huh.
You two really are getting along well tonight.
So...
Yeah.
Gonzalo.
Like...
You can help me understand where I went wrong with my new decorating.
We could kiss.
Oh.
Grace.
I'm gonna ask her.
Okay, here.
We don't need to do that.
Oh.
I'm back on the couch.
You know, I've been collecting these little glass sculptures...
Did you paint this?
Yeah.
The...
Well, it's funny how after a full day's work designing magazine ads, Grace finds the time to decorate.
And...
Redecorate.
I guess it's just the artist in me dying to get out.
Oh.
Wait.
So, yeah.
I just bought this painting.
But, God.
You know, it looks like an amateur painted it.
You...
You painted it.
Ugh.
Well, it looks so amateurish.
Doesn't it?
No.
It's awesome.
Oh.
How nice.
I've been waiting so long for someone to say that.
Grace.
I'm gonna hug her.
Wait.
What?
Tripp, our friend has just been refreshingly on...
Oh.
You're hugging me.
No.
I'm comforting you.
Oh.
That's...
Nice, Grace.
I think a hug was just what you needed.
Can you give us a...
A second?
Tripp?
All right.
Good.
Maybe you're on my side tonight after all.
Can you...
Can you give us a moment, Tripp?
Why does he always look like...
You're not enjoying this, are you?
What?
Why do they always look like they're...
Tripp, have you noticed we're fighting in front of our friend?
Like, heads are backwards.
You know?
Come on.
That kind of...
That kind of statement is not helpful.
Tripp, there's nothing wrong with...
This is me.
I'm having so much fun.
What?
What do you mean?
Gonzalo?
Yeah?
I want you to look at this photo from our recent trip to Italy.
No.
Oh, no, no.
Go look at Tripp's Italy photo.
So, come on.
I'd rather be with you, Grace.
I want you to look at this.
Go take a look.
Gonzalo.
Come on.
Just take a look at this picture.
No.
This is your idea of an enjoyable evening with friends.
Stop pressuring me.
No.
Come on.
Come take a look.
No.
Tripp, you see?
Your fetish for all things European is making our friend very uncomfortable.
I'm uncomfortable.
Damn it, Grace.
This was supposed to be our second honeymoon.
What?
Gonzalo.
Tripp is absolutely exaggerating.
Look at this photograph.
Wait.
See?
I just wanted us to spend some time together.
All those business trips of yours to Europe must have done something to you.
Ugh.
You're driving me insane.
You're driving me crazy.
You're tearing me apart.
Goddamn, Italy.
I tried to reach out to you.
How am I supposed to raise them?
I try to be romantic with you, but you're cold and distant.
I do.
I really try.
Stop yelling at me.
Why?
Gonzalo.
Yes?
I...
Yeah.
Gonzalo.
I know what you're about to say.
How I...
With your damn kissing and flirting Christ.
Grace.
Goddamn second honeymoon.
Tripp, our whole marriage, you're so...
Huh?
What?
What was that?
I didn't do anything.
Goddamn manipulation.
Grace.
I just want to be together and be happy.
I'm comforting.
Can you just see that?
Can't we just do that?
I'm comforting.
All right.
You know what?
Gonzalo.
Yeah.
I'm going to ask you something.
Tripp.
Grace.
I'm in love with your wife.
Can we ask our guest a question?
Comforting.
I'm comforting.
Gonzalo.
Yes or no?
It's okay for a married person to talk and be friendly with someone of the opposite sex.
Right?
Oh.
What?
Um.
I mean, come on.
If you're married, a little bit of harmless flirting and joking around is allowed.
Am I right?
Yes or no?
What?
Oh.
Okay.
Fine.
Wait.
Is this...
The real truth is, Tripp, you flirt with everybody.
The clients at work.
Our friends.
Everybody.
You can't help yourself.
You're always looking around.
Our entire marriage.
Goddamn it.
Oh.
Yeah.
Go on.
Go away.
I can't freaking take this.
Are you okay?
Are you okay, Grace?
What the?
Goddamn it.
Are you okay, Grace?
Comfort.
Uh.
Gonzalo.
Comfort.
What?
I can't hear you.
Are you talking?
I was not talking.
Gonzalo.
Oh.
Yeah.
In what you said before about flirting.
Where'd you go?
I think that shows us something about Tripp.
Gonzalo.
Where'd you go?
We're talking about me, are we?
What?
Damn it, Tripp.
You and my parents are always planning these stupid trips I have to go on.
They're vacations.
Expensive ones at that.
What's wrong with vacations?
Of course, nobody thinks to ask me what I want.
What do you...
What do you want, Grace?
Oh.
She looked at me.
What?
She wants me to ask.
You want to know more?
Thank you.
That helps.
Grace, you never want to go on vacation with me and your parents.
So I have to plan everything.
Ugh.
She doesn't want to go on vacation.
Let's talk some more about Grace.
Yeah.
Comfort.
Yes.
Thanks.
But what we need right now is to just get all this out in the open.
I'm hugging.
Jesus.
Gonzalo...
Yes!
Quit it with that stuff.
Oh.
Look, why don't we talk about us?
Jesus, Gonzalo, quit it with that stuff.
I'm doing what you won't.
Let's talk some more about Grace.
Tripp, you're the reason we live.
Oh, we're back at this one.
Okay.
And so...
Your triangles are so... personal.
I... it's... it's... um... wonderful.
Triangles.
It's not stupid.
It's not stupid!
Oh my God.
So triangular.
Bing bing bing bing bing.
Bing bing bing bing.
Gonzalo.
Why do you say my name!
You... you're an artist.
Uh, Gonzalo, you know we already talked about that.
Okay, um...
Paint.
Comfort.
No!
Gonzalo.
What?
I'm gonna...
Can I kiss her?
I can kiss her.
You think if I try to, she'll get mad?
No.
What?
No!
Why do you mean...
Wait!
What?
The game is... the game is... what?
The game is... what?
Hello?
You think I'm lying?
Yes.
Yes?
Yeah.
Look how sad he looks.
Oh, he's crying!
Oh, you...
Does anyone...
He looks so sad.
We should... we should talk about Tripp.
See, Grace?
He's crying.
He's crying and you want to talk...
I'm turning this into such a big issue.
I still say advertising is the best thing for you.
Best for me or for you?
What?
Gonzalo.
Yes?
I think you should paint.
Okay.
I'm sick of this bullshit.
What is this over here?
Gonzalo.
I know what you're hinting at.
Okay?
What?
About me?
Yeah.
About art?
What are these?
Do you two want the truth?
Huh?
What is this over here?
Yeah?
Gonzalo.
Do you want to hear it?
No.
I don't care what you have to say.
Grace?
Yes?
See?
Gonzalo.
I've been paying attention to what you've been saying tonight.
Yeah?
What?
You've been pushing me tonight.
Oh.
I'm pushing you on me.
And I wonder, are you really my friend?
Or not?
Tripp?
No.
Gonzalo.
Quit interrupting me.
Let me finish.
No.
Gonzalo.
I asked you this.
No.
Yes or no?
Oh?
Do you really think that praising me, asking if we're okay...
I'm...
I'm praising you?
Kissing Grace?
But especially what you said about harmless flirting.
And you don't even say yes when I ask you if you want the truth?
Okay.
That I'm supposed to realize something about myself from all that.
Is what you've said tonight supposed to add up somehow to something?
Maybe.
Is it?
I just want a yes or no.
Oh.
Okay.
Yes.
Grace?
Yes?
I know you want to be an artist.
But I could never be married to you if you were.
I'm gonna kiss her.
What?
I can't.
I just can't.
But Tripp...
When I married you, see, I was sure I could convince you to give it up.
I don't think she cares.
And advertising.
Oh.
And I did it.
And it worked.
European kiss.
But no.
I don't know, Grace.
European.
I don't know.
Grace?
Oh my God.
Oh.
Gonzalo.
I...
What?
Gonzalo.
This changes everything.
I...
Gonzalo.
U.
I.
E.
U.
Yes.
It does change everything.
No.
Gonzalo.
Hold on.
Yes?
Where is he going?
He's stomping over there.
I think it's over.
Okay.
Tripp?
What?
No.
It's over, Grace.
Don't you see that?
She doesn't see anything.
She's only looking at me.
You just told me...
I just told you something about me I should have said a long time ago.
What's that?
I can't be married to an artist.
This guy sucks so much.
What do you have against art?
Gonzalo.
Please.
It's okay.
Tripp.
No.
I...
No, Grace.
This is about...
It's about me.
I see now.
It's not about you or about our marriage.
Me?
Our marriage?
Where did he go?
Hey, no.
Wait.
Gonzalo.
I'm sorry.
Thank you, though.
You really helped me.
He's actually leaving.
Oh, get...
Tripp.
Get out of here, Tripp.
It's our house.
Tripp.
It's our house now.
Oh, my God.
I should have told him that...
That I wanted to be an artist.
Oh, my gosh.
Free wife with the house.
Let's go.
This might actually be a better ending for them.
We're free wife with the house.
Yippee.
What?
The what?
I really want an ending where, like, she kind of falls for me, though.
Hmm.
I wonder if that even exists.
It's our wife now.
Oh, my God.
Well...
This game is crazy.
Need more Riz.
All right.
This time...
You.
You guys are telling me what to type.
Okay?
And I'll type it at any moment.
It might be hard because some of the stuff is kind of quickly timed.
Okay?
But you guys have to tell me what to type.
Say what you have to say and I'll do it.
Okay.
Wah!
Thank you, Ms. Miss!
Don't tell me what I can't do.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Alright.
Just say yes to everything.
Melon speedrun.
See ya, Tripp.
Alright.
We could come out of this with a new wife.
I'm just saying.
If you play your cards right.
Answer everything with Bazinga.
Stop!
I already said Melon!
I already said Melon.
Subtitles.
Oh!
Ah!
There we go.
Okay.
Alright.
First of all...
Do we knock on the door or do we just stand out here?
And what do we say when he greets us?
Lemon.
Okay.
I'm saying mostly just stand.
So we're just gonna stand.
Can I leave actually?
Gonzalo!
Ding!
Oh no!
He had to sit through the...
I'm so sorry.
We have to sit through it again.
Okay.
I think I will make this the last run though.
Actually.
I will make this probably the last one.
What?
I just...
I just... I knew what was coming.
I heard them arguing and I was like, I'm not dealing with your...
I'm not dealing with your...
With your...
With this tonight.
I cannot deal.
I cannot deal with it.
I do not have the...
The patience, the mental capacity.
Failed marriage.
If I never go in there, what do you think happens I wonder?
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Not dealing with your BS.
So true.
Okay.
Final Gonzalo.
Here we go.
Okay.
I'm going to stand here.
Standing here.
I realize this is a waste of time.
Okay.
You know, I've had to ask you about this several...
I'll get rid of it in just a minute.
Fine, Tripp.
Fine.
Wait, what is she not like?
Um, I'm here.
Gonzalo.
Hey.
I thought I heard someone out here.
Great to see you.
It's been a while.
How's it going?
What should I say?
Oh, hi, Mark.
Hi.
Wow.
It's really, really great to see you.
Come on in.
Your name's Mark now.
Got it?
Uh...
Yeah.
It'll be just a sec while I go get Grace.
Grace?
What is this?
No, no.
Here we are.
Oh.
Hello.
Gonzalo?
Hi.
Gonzalo.
How are you?
Oh, God.
It's been such a long time.
Merry Christmas.
That's funny.
I said the same thing.
Skibbity.
By the way, you look wonderful.
Um...
Well, come in.
Make yourself at home.
Out.
Close the door.
Gonzalo?
Seeing you again makes me remember the wonderful...
What?
Oh.
I'll get it.
No.
We have a guest.
We can let the answering machine pick it up.
Grace?
No.
I work...
Don't be rude.
I'll get it.
It's probably just the execs at work.
Gonzalo?
Grace?
Hello?
No.
Please don't do that.
I did it.
Who is this?
Grace?
Is that you?
Ugh.
It's my dad.
I can hear his voice.
Oh.
Well...
That's nice of you to say.
Grace, aren't you glad we invited him over?
Yeah.
Ahem.
Well, Grace's parents...
Is it really her dad?
They're something else.
Really classy people.
Ugh.
No.
They're impossible.
They expect me to drive up to the house in Connecticut...
...to attend all their stupid socialite charity benefits and parties.
It's so tiresome.
Sigh.
I...
Silence.
Well, it didn't take long for you two to bond or whatever.
What?
We bonded?
So...
What?
Gonzalo.
You can help me understand...
Your eyes?
...what went wrong with my new decorating.
Grace.
Oh.
Gonzalo.
I think you're flirting with me to get on my good side.
Oh!
Grace.
No, no, no.
He's just joking.
Oh!
What?
That worked!
The Riz!
Do you like country life?
So, about my decorating?
When I saw this armoire in the store, it seemed to have such a clean, simple look to it.
Yeah.
It looks great.
How did that work?
But looking at it here in the apartment, it just looks like a...
Go...
How...
What else?
...monstrosity.
Come on, guys.
Oh, Grace.
Your dad sounds hot.
No, no.
You've...
You've done quite enough with my parents tonight.
Let's not talk about them anymore.
Okay.
Sorry.
Grace, it seems no one has a problem with your decorating.
Guys.
Elriz.
Tripp, that's what you always say.
Grab the rainbow sculpture.
But believe me.
It needs to be redone.
Ugh.
Let's not talk about that anymore.
I'm redoing the whole place anyway.
What is this one anyway?
Hey.
Grace?
Gonzalo.
Seeing you brings back good memories, you know?
Yes.
Grace?
What is this?
Whoa.
I just realized something.
What?
Oh, tonight's a special night.
A celebration, in fact.
It is?
Celebration.
Gonzalo.
Remember?
It was almost exactly ten years ago tonight that you introduced us.
What?
Senior year of college.
Oh, jeez.
Remember that?
Sussy.
Well, without you, we wouldn't even have this celebration.
I'm just reading.
I'm just putting in what you guys write.
Gonzalo.
You probably didn't come here to hear this.
Wait, wait.
What's wrong, Tripp?
Tripp, it's okay if we disagree in front of our friend.
Why?
We're not disagreeing.
Who is this?
Oh, who is this?
I thought you might like this photo I just put up from our recent trip to Italy.
It's a beautiful picture of the Italian countryside.
Of course he'll like it.
Grace?
I don't know if you don't like it, but our friend might.
Gonzalo?
I'm looking.
By the way, anybody, join me on the couch if you like.
Um...
Okay.
Now...
Gonzalo?
Yeah?
In one word, what does this picture say to you?
Don't care.
It'll...
Well, actually, this trip to Italy was meant to be our second honeymoon.
Wow.
So...
Oh, was that what it was?
Huh.
I'm always the last to know.
Grace?
Why is it like...
Also, we have music this time and everything.
It's interesting.
So...
In a word, this says...
Grace stayed behind in the hotel room when I was out taking this picture.
Oh.
Romance.
Right.
Love.
Romance.
Oh, but the last time I said love, you kicked me out.
In our marriage, that's just a code word for manipulation.
Grace, it's been such a long time since we had a chance to be friends back then.
I'm sorry.
I was curious about that.
That's what he would say if I agreed with him.
... without even asking me if I wanted to go.
I was curious what he'd say.
Gonzalo, that's not the first time he's done that.
Oh.
And you knew I planned to attend my friend's art show that weekend.
What?
That's new.
A very good friend from college had a gallery show of his new paintings that weekend, and I missed it.
To be saved with joy.
Thank you for the gift of...
Ugh.
This is bullshit.
No.
You're full of shit.
Goddamn romance.
I need to shit.
What?
I...
What are you saying to me?
Well, you just said... you know...
Gonzalo, I...
You said that you're full and I'm...
Oh.
And you...
I know what you're going to say.
You've been critical of me all evening.
I have?
I said...
I compliment...
I flirted with you.
Your goddamn parents.
I...
You think you're better than me just because I don't come for...
I flirted with you.
Oh, sure.
What?
What are you saying to me?
Oh.
Babycore, thanks for the gift, then.
All right.
You know what?
Gonzalo...
Start speaking, Kevin.
I'm going to...
I need to ask you something.
Grace...
Oh.
Tripp, let me ask our guest a question.
Stop sabotaging us.
Gonzalo...
Yes or no?
Okay.
Do you think it's wrong for one person in a marriage to listen too much to the other?
What?
To trust your husband or wife too much.
To rely on them too much.
Is that wrong?
Yes or no?
Okay.
You guys are saying yes.
Yes.
What?
You guys said yes.
Oh.
All right.
Yeah.
I keep trying to help you, Grace, but you reject me.
You cut me off.
You cut me out of your life.
Oh, my God.
God damn it.
His cake.
When he was walking away.
Did you guys see him?
I can't stand you.
God damn it.
What is this?
What should I say?
What should I do to...
I'll comfort her.
No.
Wait.
Please.
What?
Are you talking about me in there?
I wasn't talking about you.
Gonzalo, I can't believe you have to see this.
Oh, comfort.
I comfort her.
I comfort...
Kiss her.
Oh, no.
Don't do that.
God.
Oh.
Grace, are you talking about me?
What do you care?
You guys, I think...
I don't think she liked it.
Gonzalo.
Oh, shit.
Grace is just so...
We're talking about me, are we?
What?
Grace, even though now you're a creative director at this point...
And even though you redecorate the apartment all the time, the truth is, you're not an artist.
Why did you...
I'm sorry.
Wait.
Where'd she go?
Gonzalo.
Uh-oh.
Oh, my God.
Um...
Gonzalo.
Yes?
You see, this is what I've had to put up with for ten goddamn years.
I thought this was a celebration.
Look.
Let's not focus on just me or you.
Let's talk about us both.
Trip.
Can't you see?
It's the way you speak.
The way you talk to me.
What?
I'm not allowed to talk to you.
I'm not allowed to be angry.
Teleports behind you.
You tell me what to do.
You don't listen.
I love you, Grace.
Gonzalo.
Okay.
I'm not telling her what to do.
I'm trying to help her.
I'm gonna tell her.
I love you, Grace.
Look.
Quit the flirting already.
I'm not gonna put up with that at this point.
Jesus.
Let's keep talking about Grace.
Okay.
Gonzalo.
It's time that Trip finally just admits that our marriage...
Grace, don't.
You don't need to.
Admits that our marriage is not...
Stop it.
Stop interrupting her.
Wait.
How do you spell interrupting?
Okay.
Stop interrupting her.
No.
God.
Let's keep our focus on Grace.
You know, Trip, whenever I really try to talk honestly...
You know what?
Gonzalo.
That's it.
You need to leave.
No.
I'm sorry, but I don't know what to do with you tonight.
Grace.
He's kicking...
He's stopping our love.
Grace.
We'll be fine.
Just go.
Grace.
No.
Oh.
Someone said in the chat.
Say I love you.
I tried.
Grace.
Bye, Charmaine.
Should have kissed Trip.
It's a very broken relationship here.
Yeah.
Should have went for the dad.
This is terrifying.
Oh, my God.
Oh, Gonzalo.
Can't stop our love, Trip.
Hop, hop, hop, hop!
Welcome to Bamboo Ship.
Thank you guys so much!
Break!
Thanks for the 50!
Thank you!
Thank you for the 50 gift!
It's interesting how very the dialogue can even be.
Into.
This.
We've gotten the one where they stay together and talk things out.
We've gotten the ending where obviously we were kicked out.
We've gotten the ending where Trip walks out.
We haven't... sorry.
We haven't seen Grace walk out.
They're incredibly awful but interesting.
The game was way out of its time.
You can walk around, you can pick stuff up, they interact, you can type whatever.
It's kind of insane.
And then there's so much that's already been recorded.
So I need to probably... okay, let's do one more.
I know I said that was the last one but we're gonna try and do one more where we side with Trip, unfortunately.
To... uh... to... um...
Then see if we can get Grace to leave.
One more!
Bromance route time.
We're gonna do a really cool handshake together.
Oh, I... oh yes, I could be a girl name this time.
I guess you're right.
Oh, I guess you're right, I guess you're right, I guess you're right.
Does anyone... like... I mean... like... can Grace like get like a knife from the kitchen or something?
Like... or... or Trip?
Can either of them like kind of... like... I wanna see them actually go insane.
Wait, so if we're not Gonzalo...
Gonzalina?
Sadly, no.
Dang.
Let's see, what?
There we go.
Amy.
Let's just go with Amy.
Actually, is uh... is Gen... Genivra?
Is that a girl's name?
I wanna see how... I wanna know how that's spelled.
Lisa, you're tearing me apart, Lisa!
Ippie Minto.
I know, I don't know why I'm so ippie today.
Let's just try it.
Okay, or there is Lisa.
Oh, where'd it go?
Li... Lisa.
Okay.
Let's start.
Oh, hi Mark.
Alright.
We're on Trip's...
We're on Trip's side.
Wah.
Huh?
You told me it'd be an hour from now.
No, she's supposed to be here now.
Oh my gosh.
And they changed everything so it's Tree.
Wow.
Lisa!
Trip!
I'm so happy you could make it.
Oh, hi.
Yeah, hi.
Wow, it's so great to see you after so long.
Hello.
Come on in.
Hi.
Well, come in.
Yeah, I...
Uh, it'll be just a sec while I go get Grace.
Ugh, I hate Grace.
Ugh.
Kiss him?
I don't wanna get kicked... wait.
Should I kiss him while...
Grace is not here.
I should have kissed him.
No, no.
Here we are.
Bye-bye.
Lisa.
Hi.
How are you?
I'm...
And I've got to say, you look really good.
Make yourself at home.
Come on in.
Oh, I think we're gonna need to have some drinks first if we're gonna talk about sex.
Oh.
Trip, come on.
That's not funny.
Lisa, I should warn you, I never know how much of what I say is true.
Hey, Lisa, seeing you brings back sweet memories.
You... you think I'm communicative?
Haha, huh.
Oh, you're... you're quite the kidder tonight.
Yeah.
Never afraid to say anything that pops into your mind.
Oh, yeah.
Boobies!
Hey... wait.
Did you...
Yeah.
Take out the garbage like I asked you to?
Oh, good question.
What?
The garbage?
Yes.
Did you take out the garbage under the kitchen sink?
Yeah.
Oh, alright.
Good.
I just wanted to make sure you hadn't forgotten that.
Whoa, I just realized something.
When's the last time you were...
Oh, tonight's a special night.
Oh.
Yeah.
Tonight is special.
Intimate.
Lisa, remember...
Uh, well, remember how you introduced us almost exactly ten years ago today?
Don't ignore me!
Yes.
We really want to thank you for years and years of pain.
Sexy time.
Lisa, flirting with me will only make it harder to let you leave tonight.
Don't get carried away, Tripp.
She's just telling you what you want to hear.
What does that mean?
Sexy time.
If I just keep saying sexy time, you think it's a...
Oh, Lisa.
I thought you might like this photo I just put up from our recent trip to Italy.
Italy?
Might like it.
It's a beautiful picture of the Italian countryside.
Of course she'll like it.
Lisa, come take a look at this.
Yes, go take a look.
By the way, anybody join me on the couch if you want?
Tripp, I want you?
Um, no.
Lisa, what does this picture make you think of?
Romance.
Think of?
Right!
Love!
Romance!
Everything in Italy was so romantic.
The scenery, the food, the wine...
I want to go with you, Tripp.
Well, um, but it was the art that was so amazing.
The art...
Ah, you hate that!
Oh my god, he said the A word!
Art!
I want you, Tripp.
Wait, wait, what's wrong, Tripp?
Tripp, it's okay if we disagree in front of our friend.
We're not disagreeing.
No, no.
Comfort.
You're hugging me.
Lisa, careful.
Too much affection can go to Tripp's head.
Right.
It's okay, it's okay.
Well, you're really affectionate tonight, aren't you?
Sexy time.
Oh, Lisa, how funny.
You're flirting with me.
I am?
Okay, okay, that's enough.
Let's not go there.
How far can we go?
You know, ever since we got married, Tripp is forever trying to get me to buy new furniture and redecorate.
Well, really aggressive all of a sudden.
And it's true, I kind of enjoy it, but...
I'm scared.
Well, um, well, I want to ask you...
You are very, you're very aggressive.
Lisa, you have to look at this room and admit it looks terrible.
Terrible.
I mean, look over...
No, no, no, no, no.
See, Grace loves expensive furniture.
She grew up in this really nice house with really nice couches and fancy dishes.
And she can't live without this stuff.
She's not like other girls.
She doesn't want to wear pearls.
You know, at work, I waste all day designing ads for apartments with perfect views like this.
She wants to wear...
And it makes me think I want to design it into my apartment.
This view makes me feel like a million bucks.
Oh my gosh, you know, she wants to wear paperclips.
Dammit, I'm wrong.
I simply want a view of trees and green.
Trees?
What?
Trees are disgusting.
Ah, what a nice surprise and honest answer.
Lisa.
Wait, Grace.
I don't know where you're getting this.
But that's what you said.
You, you, you, you.
You did that painting on the wall instead of buying it.
Oh, yeah.
We've seen how your artist friends live.
As if you could survive that kind of lifestyle.
Give me a break.
Give me, give me a break.
Lisa.
No, no, no, you're being honest.
I'm being honest?
Okay, well, I was worried there for a bit that you were on tripside tonight.
I am.
Oh, no.
No, no, hold on.
Lisa.
I gotta get back on tripside.
Lisa, stop that.
It's embarrassing already.
God.
Oh.
That's the last one I'll do.
Or else they'll kick me out.
So, drinks.
Drinks.
Chip's favorite pastime is to get the blood alcohol content of his guests higher than his golf score.
Why don't I make us one of my new drink inventions?
I call it Grace's Inner Soul.
It's a mixture of Chardonnay bitters and lots of ice.
I'd love that.
Ah.
Lisa.
You have deliciously wicked taste.
I'm going to make you one of my new drink inventions.
Oh, yes.
It's a secret.
Trip doesn't even like the taste of alcohol.
What?
So, Lisa.
How does that sound?
Lisa.
Chip's getting a little carried away.
I'd love a drink.
Maybe you just want some juice.
No.
Or a mineral water.
Yeah.
No.
I'm going to make this drink for us.
Give me the whole bottle.
Our friend is here.
We're going to enjoy ourselves.
That's all there is to it.
Yeah.
Please.
Everybody loves my drinks.
Hey, everybody loves his drinks, Grace.
You know that, don't you?
Everybody loves his drinks.
Well, of course, Trip.
After all, you got enough practice when you were a real bartender.
What?
In college, you were a bartender.
How do you know about that?
Oh, I know you were trying to keep it a big secret, but...
One time, my friends and I went slumming off campus to some crappy bar in the sticks, and we saw you there.
What?
Oh, that's great.
Oh.
This is bullshit.
I love bartenders.
No.
You're full of shit.
What's wrong with being a bartender?
What is wrong with that?
What?
What are you saying?
I love bartenders.
What's wrong with being a bartender?
Lisa.
I...
Huh?
Oh.
And you're a bartender.
And you.
I can predict what you'll say.
The way you keep trying to explain everything.
Um, sexy time?
Look, just quit the flirting right now.
I'm warning you.
Goddamn.
Flirt.
What is everybody hinting at?
That I'm a bad person?
Oh, my God.
That I don't love my wife?
What?
Ugh.
All right.
You know what?
Lisa?
I'm going to ask you something.
Okay.
Grace, Tripp, let me ask our guest a question.
What?
Okay.
Lisa?
Yes or no?
Should a married person be allowed to flirt with other people for fun?
Oh, yes.
What?
Why?
See?
Oh, yes.
That's fine.
What?
What's that look on your face for, huh?
The real truth is, Tripp, you flirt with everybody.
Come on.
The clients at work, our friends, everybody.
You can't help yourself.
You're always looking around.
Our entire marriage.
Goddamn it.
She's gone.
Yeah.
Go on.
Get out of my face.
Come here.
I can't hear a freaking look at you.
What the...
Oh, hey.
Come here.
Goddamn it.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Hold on.
Before she comes back.
Ugh.
Where'd you go?
Oh, no.
No.
Don't do that.
What, Tripp?
Why are you trying to talk to me?
What's it to you?
I'm trying to kiss him.
Lisa.
Tripp can just be so...
Oh.
We're talking about me, are we?
What?
It's your fault.
Ten years ago, freshly married and just out of college...
You guys are so dramatic.
I need like...
You convinced me to go into advertising instead of art.
...to listen to some relaxing ASMR after this or something.
If it weren't for you, I could be a real artist by now.
Lisa.
Ugh.
Your art sucks.
This painting.
Well, see, all I really wanted was something personal.
It's bad.
No.
Look, there's nothing wrong with the stupid painting.
I guess there is.
Well, it makes me feel like shit.
Ugh.
You feel like that for no reason.
It's bad.
Look, let's not focus on just me or you.
Let's talk about us.
No art.
Lisa, you blame me for all of this, don't you?
Yes.
See, Grace?
You're the one.
Yes?
Yes.
Oh my god.
You think I'm to blame.
I'm to blame for all of this.
Yes.
Yes?
Art bad.
Art...
This is too much.
I can't take this.
Go away.
No.
Just leave me alone for a second.
I don't want to...
Ugh.
Okay.
Lisa.
You know what?
I think you should leave.
No.
You'll be fine.
You should just go.
Why?
What happened?
What?
I was too freaky?
No.
I know.
Did you ever see the AR room this game was made for?
It's just a guy with a prototype VR goggles and a giant backpack on.
Really?
I've never seen it.
Trip rejected me.
But I didn't...
But I didn't do anything.
Another one.
What do you mean another one?
Thank you.
Thank you for the gift, did you guys?
More smooth...
I didn't know he was a bartender.
MMM.
Manless Maiden.
What do you mean?
Wait,
no!
There's literally Phantom Tax!
Worry, thank you for the Phantom Tax!
Thank you!
It wasn't me.
Someone sent that.
KBarn.
Blame KBarn.
KBarn made me read that.
Can love bloom between a bartender and an artist?
I've learned so much about these two.
That Trip has some really deep rooted problems.
With his upbringing.
He wants to be one of the Joneses.
And Grace hates how she grew up.
And doesn't want to live this fancy lifestyle.
He has an inferiority complex.
Yes!
Why does he hate art?
Thank you for the gift.
You have the interesting glitch face.
Thank you!
He hates occupations in general.
I don't know why...
Right now, YouTube chat is kinda glitching for me.
So I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna refresh.
I'm gonna refresh!
Bum bum bum bum bum bum bum!
Bum bum bum bum bum bum!
Wait.
Oh.
Hold on.
YouTube?
Uh-oh.
I think everything's crashing.
I think... maybe I'm in trouble.
Oh wait, wait, there we go.
And... there.
Okay.
Hold.
Quick while she can't see.
I can see!
That was fun.
That was interesting.
That was something for sure.
What?
Why?
First of all, why?
I guess we got the quote-unquote good end, right?
Where they talk it out.
That was a game.
Gonzalo and Lisa got married.
Gonzalo!
The fact that... the way they say the name so often, it's just really funny.
What's the good ending?
Where they...
You got two good endings, isn't bad.
Is him leaving a good ending, I guess?
Oh my gosh, Andre goes, thank you for the 50!
Thank you!
You guys are insane!
You guys are so crazy.
Thank you so much!
Oh, elevator ending.
That's true.
That was maybe the best ending.
Just avoid it all.
Leave it.
Leave it to them.
I don't know why we became a marriage counselor.
What a mysterious game.
Truly.
Truly mysterious.
Seriously.
If I remember correctly, she is cheating on him!
What?
Oh my gosh, Mr. LBC, thank you for the 50!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Oh my gosh, you guys are crazy!
Please.
I know that the memberships are not as expensive as usually.
But like, please.
Please.
Wait, so is that really not her dad?
He's cheating on her too?
Well, she said...
She said that...
He flirts with everybody.
Domingo, thanks for the gifted!
Ryzen, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Oh my gosh, welcome!
Welcome, welcome, welcome!
Slay, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
I think they have a lot of issues.
I think we can all agree...
That they have...
Issues.
And maybe...
You know...
If you're in a relationship and you're just like...
Hmm, is this going well?
PluginBeta, thank you for the 50!
S1, thank you for the 20!
Jace, thank you for the 10!
Oh my gosh.
If you are in a...
If you are in a relationship and you're like...
Man, I have issues.
Or, if you're not in a relationship...
This is something that...
You...
Are missing out on.
Isn't that so sad?
And...
Alessandro, thank you for the 10!
Kat, thank you for the 50!
CaseyRaptor, thank you!
Thank you for the 5!
Sophia, thank you for the 10!
Kuma, welcome!
Dexteria, thank you for the 50!
Why is everybody giving 50 membership?
My...
My notifications are never going to end!
Oh my gosh.
ShadyNoctis, thank you for the 50!
Thank you guys so much!
Thank you!
I have...
I don't even know how many emotes I can commission at this point.
Here, let me see.
I don't even know.
Um...
Memberships.
Holy cow!
So...
Oh!
Wow!
Hold on.
Let me see.
Okay.
Emoji.
1...
2...
3...
4...
5...
6...
7...
8...
9...
10...
11...
16...
17...
18...
19...
20...
21...
22...
23...
24...
25...
26...
27...
28...
29...
30!
This is...
This is not including the ones that I already have.
31...
32...
33...
34...
35...
36...
37...
That might fill it up.
Because it's not letting me add another one, but it's not telling me that I need to get more members.
37...
38...
39...
40...
41...
42...
45...
46...
47...
48...
49...
51...
52...
53...
54...
55...
Oh, we have all the slots already?
I guess so!
I have to commission so many emotes.
Suffering from success.
37.
We need some glow sticks?
There's one with me holding glow sticks.
It's this one.
It's kind of...
Maybe it's a little smaller.
I'm holding the glow sticks.
Oh my god.
Emofa, thank you!
Thank you for the Uncle Silva!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Please, you're gifting too many.
Everybody gifted a lot last time!
Wow.
Thank you, guys.
It's a sea of green.
For real.
I'm curious what the generated stage play is, but it like opens up a...
It opens up like a...
What's it called?
Is it a text file?
What is this?
Cannot find the program...
Files...
Facades...
Stage plays...
Stage play...
Text file...
Do you want to create a new file?
Yes?
There's nothing here.
It's empty.
Can we have a wisp, Emo?
Yes, I will.
I have many things I must...
Must...
Oh my gosh, Lucy, thank you.
I have many things I must...
I must...
Of...
Decide on how...
What emotes now.
Oh my gosh.
Hey, boss, YouTube charged my account wrong for membership.
So here's the rest of it with interest.
Oh, wake up block, thank you.
But yeah.
Hey, many people have been asking, have you seen Akiba Maid War?
If not, love a live react to the OP.
Oh, I could probably do that, right?
I'll be honest, I haven't.
I still haven't seen it.
I'm so bad.
I know.
It's like literally...
Made for me.
Get it?
CrunchyPVJ!
Just like free...
You know, emotes are free, so...
Fake needs, stop!
I...
Why?
I have...
I can...
Be...
I am fine with the emotes.
I just have to find an artist.
I've gotta...
I have to find an artist who's...
Who I could be like, can you make 30 emotes?
So...
Oh...
Okay, um...
What was I looking up?
Oh.
Akiba.
Mid-war opening.
Do you think I can just watch it?
I've...
Made...
Nice...
Mints.
Finger guns in my door.
Thank you for the aqua soup bar.
Thank you!
Let me...
I'm gonna...
Give me a second.
No, no, no, no, no.
We're gonna watch it together.
You think it's fine though?
If...
Maybe I won't get copy...
If I talk enough, maybe I won't get copyright struck.
And I don't...
I won't make it so loud.
Um...
Let me...
Do this.
Well, I'm just gonna do the same window capture.
Uh...
Made...
Dai...
Kaiten.
Wait, how do I...
Oh, here.
This one.
I crop it, I crop it, crop, crop, crop, crop it.
Crop, crop, crop, crop it.
Transition?
Transition.
How do I transition?
Hello?
Why won't you...
Why won't you let me?
What's going on?
Oh!
I'm in stu...
For some reason it wouldn't let me...
That's weird.
Okay.
Time to watch the Akiba Maid Wars opening.
For the first time, I've never watched it before.
Wow...
This is from a year ago, when it was uploaded.
Oh, I guess it was from last year, wasn't it?
Joseph, thank you for your Akasuba!
Thank you.
Finally!
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Velen Books!
No!
I'm sorry.
Suika Books!
It says...
Wait, so if this is...
If this is... okay.
If this is this area, then that means there's Arcade, and then there's Super Potato, and then this would be...
It said Tsukimo, but maybe it's supposed to be the Kotobukiya.
If it's this area.
Wow!
Hey, that's me!
Why is she blocked out?
Do the characters get introduced?
Oh my gosh, the Momoi!
The Momoi dokei!
It's so fast.
So this is... this clock is like...
It's really...
It's like one of those... how do I say?
Oh my gosh, sorry.
It's um...
It's uh...
Yeah, it's very famous!
That's the word!
It's a legendary clock in Akihabara!
It's right outside the station.
Towards the Radio Kaikan building side.
Legendary clock.
So it's really cool that they included it.
This is such a jam.
Wait, hold on.
I know I keep stopping and like going through.
But I wanna see like what they include.
Of course, there's a train.
Which one is this supposed to be?
I guess it's just supposed to be one of the... wait, hm?
Hm, I guess it's maybe... hm?
What building is this supposed to be?
Actual electronic shop, wow.
Yeah, they still exist!
They still exist in Akihabara.
Oh no, Den is huge!
They're so cute, I love their outfits so much.
Wow.
Are they actually fighting so many people?
Oh cute!
The confetti...
I'm surprised the confetti doesn't ruin the bitrate.
Why is it such a bop though?
Oh, bop bop bop bop bop!
But no...
This area...
This almost looks like...
This actually looks like Yodobashi.
It looks like.
I don't know if it is or not though.
Like Yodobashi camera.
That was so cute.
Such a bop.
I could be getting this area wrong, right?
Because it's...
If it's Kimo...
I don't know.
If it's the melon books...
But it depends on if this is Chuo Dori or not.
Because it...
Because if it's the...
Sorry, I'm getting all confused now.
I'm getting all confused now.
Tsukumo.
Yeah, Tsukumo!
But...
The area I'm thinking of...
See, there's Akibao right there.
Oh, sorry.
Oki...
Okibao.
Akibao.
Quick, take us to Google Street View.
You're so right.
Oki...
Okibao.
So funny.
Akibao?
There's several in Akiba though.
Those are also like...
Popular electronic stores in Akibao.
Geoguessr Mint.
I'm no...
What's that guy's name?
It's funny because...
Besides the Suika books...
The opening shows like mostly...
It doesn't show like any of the anime like...
Stuff.
It mostly focuses on like...
You know...
You can see like the DVD...
Like stores that you can buy and sell stuff.
And then...
There's the computer.
Sembon Store.
Doesn't focus on all the anime stuff there is around in the area too.
Thanks for the fun stream Mint!
I need to sleep now!
Good night!
Things are hanging out!
Thank you!
Think this might be an alley parallel to the main road.
I think so too.
But that's why I'm...
That's why my brain is like...
Where are we?
Cuz...
Okay!
This looks like the building that has...
Well, maybe not.
It looks like the building that has the main dream in it.
Which would make sense if this were...
If this were...
The Kinokuniya...
Sorry.
Kotobukiya.
And then if this were the melon books...
Because the melon...
But the melon books you have to go...
You...
You have to...
You either go through the...
What's the word?
The...
The arcade?
Or you go around to the front?
But this looks like Chuo Dori over here.
So I don't know.
I don't know.
Oh my gosh.
I'm a fake Akiba fan.
This anime takes place in the 90s?
Oh!
90s?
The 90s?
Oh!
There was the windows.
Yeah.
That's right.
Where did it go?
They did have the windows.
Oh.
Windmill.
Windmill 95.
Were there even maid cafes back then?
Mysterious.
Old-timey Akiba.
Sometimes I...
There's like...
Sometimes I'll go through like...
Sites that have like...
Old shops and stuff that were in Akiba.
I just like to read about them.
During the maid wars.
That's why there's no maids!
Because they're still...
They're at war!
I get it.
I understand now.
Anyway.
That was...
That was fun.
That was silly.
I'm going to...
Move over...
Here.
Hello.
And I'm gonna...
I'm gonna...
One second.
I'm gonna put on some BGM.
And I'm...
Oh.
Let me exit out of the facade game too.
Exit.
Okay.
And...
BGM.
Where was my music?
Why can't I ever find it?
There we go...
Thank you for the ten gifted...
Smash a boo!
No!
Oh!
I want melon bread now.
No, the song is called Lemon Cake.
You're so close.
I still haven't even...
I'm still using all the same BGM I used to use in the past.
When did I even save this?
July?
Wait, this doesn't make any sense.
It says created...
August 13th, 2020.
But then it says modified...
July 18th, 2020.
How does that make any sense?
What?
How was it created in August?
Small brain!
Thank you for the 50!
Thank you!
Time travel.
Time travel real.
What?
Is it okay if I can recommend you a video called...
Eurasian waifu air force recruitment video?
Yes.
Just post it in my tag.
Emory!
Why are you gifting me?
Stop!
Oh my gosh.
You guys, next week, Emory and... Can I say that?
Can I say that we're gonna collab next week?
Well, I said it.
Gonna collab with Emory next week.
When I was in Japan, Emory and I hung out a couple times.
Yippee!
We went shopping and...
We got our hair done together and...
It was so fun.
Spoilers.
I don't know what I'm at all doing next week though.
What are we streaming?
I think we're doing a collab with a lethal company.
And I'm doing mods for the first time ever.
The one mod that I've always wanted to do was the Skinwalker mod.
Where it copies your voices?
Oh my gosh.
I'm kind of scared.
Fukuro, thanks for the 5k did!
Thank you guys, everybody joining.
Everybody gifting.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, there's like a Skinwalker mod that will like...
Copy your voice and then like...
So you'll be, you know, walking through the mines.
Swinging your pickaxe side to side, side to side.
And then you'll hear your friend and you'll be like...
Oh, hi!
But it wasn't your friend.
It was actually...
A monster.
It's genuinely so confusing.
The Goku mod!
What's that?
What's the Goku mod?
Is it just the two of you playing Lethal?
No, we have some other people.
Yes.
We have some other people.
But I've never collabed with them before.
So...
I'm a little nervous.
Yeah, yeah.
Who is he?
I'm not gonna say.
What about Matara?
I do wanna...
I do wanna play games with Matara.
I don't know.
Maybe because I talk to her so much.
Thank you so much!
Thanks for the gift!
Thank you!
Maybe because I talk with her so much.
Because of the podcast.
I'm just like, you know...
Maybe we're okay.
No, I'm just kidding.
I still do wanna play games with her, but...
I'm trying to...
Um...
Ease myself in...
To...
Collapse and stuff like that, so...
I don't know.
Just because, you know, I don't wanna...
Come and swing in...
When...
Um...
I just got back.
Yeah, yeah.
Take your time.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Maybe after the pod season.
Well, I also...
You know, I don't want people to get sick of us.
Like, if we're always on the pod...
And we're always talking...
And...
Um...
We're...
Like, you know...
I don't want it to be like...
Oh, you're...
You guys are collabing too?
Oh my gosh!
I've seen way too much of Minta Matara!
Please!
Well, obviously, we will be streaming though...
When I go and visit her and she plays Metal Gear, so...
Hmm...
So...
There's that to look forward to.
Matara overdose.
Hakuna Matara.
Metal Gear?
No.
So...
I don't know exactly how that's gonna work though.
Are we gonna watch BBC Wildlife videos?
Stop!
Bye!
My drama.
I can't believe these people are friends.
I hate that.
I love you!
NotoriousBSJ, thank you for the live gift and thank you!
Also looking at the...
Some of these are probably older streamlabs, but...
Akiba Maid War Watchalong, the show felt like watching a Yakuza show, but with maids instead.
Is there like...
Is there like any mystery to it or is it like...
Just kinda...
Not violent, but...
I don't know how to say.
Spy animals.
No spy animals!
A little mystery.
Plenty of violence.
It's quite surreal.
Thank you for the 50 gift and thank you!
Thank you.
Oh yeah, the blurred face mystery girl.
Well, I wasn't...
You know how like in some shows...
They'll blur people out or they'll like scratch people out until they're introduced in the show?
I wasn't sure if that was the case.
I like shows like that though where they change the opening.
They'll reveal more things in the opening as more stuff is revealed in the show.
It's so cool.
Low-key emotion wrecking?
Azura!
Thank you for the 50 gift and thank you!
Gakko Gurashi was great for that.
Yes!
Oh my gosh.
I think of Gakko Gurashi every time when I think of like that concept.
Gift shower and all.
Why are you guys so nice to me?
What's going on?
Did you get Rem on Nikkei?
You know what?
I'm not a huge Nikkei player.
I'm haunted.
I'm glitching.
I'm not a big Nikkei player.
I played a little bit.
How's Fuji-san doing today?
Let's check.
Fuji-san, update.
You cannot see Fuji-san.
It's cloudy.
That's typically how it is.
That's one of the reasons...
One of the few reasons I don't like summer.
It's because it's always cloudy.
Maria!
Why are you gifting?
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
I hope you've been enjoying Metal Gear.
See ya!
Bye, gilt meu.
Bye.
Bye!
Bye,
G - .
See you later!
Thank you for being so kind...
It knew how to talk.
I knew how to talk...
I'm the type that focuses mostly on one gacha game at a time.
So me and Blue Archive, we are tight.
We are so tight.
I don't see myself giving up Blue Archive.
And hopefully I don't see it disappearing from the English side anytime soon.
Hopefully.
A lot of YouTubers have been playing Metal Gear Solid lately.
I know.
So awesome.
I wonder why.
More people should play Metal Gear though.
More people should play Metal Gear and know why it's so great.
I like Asuna and Karin.
Unlike Pre-Connect.
The Master Collection?
The Master Collection, I think, helps a ton with people being able to play.
Before, obviously, you had to jump through a little bit of hoops to either, like...
You know, you could play the GOG Metal Gear Solid, but with all the issues it has...
And then...
Um...
Uh...
If you wanted to play it, you'd have to, like, get a PS3 and all this stuff.
And then also...
You have to...
All there was was the HD Collection.
Yeah.
So...
I get it.
I get why more people are playing it now.
Well, that's it.
Thanks for the fun, Captain!
Thank you, Ducky!
But yeah...
So...
Do you have any ways on how to get into Metal Gear Solid for people who want to?
Play.
Play it.
Blue Archive has many cute and funny...
Yeah!
They're so cute!
And they're so goofy!
I love them.
Rico!
Thanks for the fun, Captain!
Thank you!
Hoping 4 and Peace Walker come to PC soon.
Me too.
Yeah.
But...
There is Master Collection 2.
We'll see what happens...
in it.
Metal Gear Acid playthrough when?
I do plan on playing it.
I probably will regret it.
But I do...
There will be a time when I will play it.
Shirokuma, thank you for the PC!
Thank you for the time!
Thank you.
MGS Lore stream when?
Maybe...
Well...
I mean, we'll have the Lore podcast...
Oh, not Lore podcast.
We don't want to spoil stuff for her, right?
Thank you guys for the stream labs as well.
If you're still looking for Mystery Wrecks, I would suggest Summertime Rendering.
I...
saw that...
when I was watching Heavenly...
Delusion?
Is that what it's called?
Heavenly Delusion?
When I always finish an episode, it would recommend Summertime Rendering.
Thank you for the time!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
It was good.
I love...
time travel.
So much.
So...
So awesome.
I don't know why.
I love time travel.
I think...
I...
I think I must blame...
Girl Who Leapt Through Time.
You've seen Heavenly Delusion?
Manga is so good.
I haven't read the manga.
But...
Oh, the anime was really...
And then also, Bish did the opening.
So...
It was good.
Why are we yelling?
Have you checked Apothecary Diaries?
What is the genre of Apothecary Diaries?
Because...
I've seen a lot about it.
But I don't know anything about it.
But...
From what I saw, I thought it was like a...
Shoujo.
Or something.
Is it a mystery?
Romance?
It's like a mystery.
Kyler!
Thanks for the 10-Gifted!
Thank you!
It's so...
It's Anime!
Breaking Bad!
What?
Historical mystery...
Romance, mystery and romance.
Are you...
It's like a mystery.
Is it a mystery?
What is...
This looks like... This looks like MGS5 is my first game though.
Let's me be really confused.
Yeah, I can believe that.
Hey, I'm Dragon, thank you for the 20!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, you guys are...
No wonder...
No wonder we hit the...
No wonder we hit the amount...
The max amount of...
Of uh...
Oh my god.
Wait.
You guys, I think we have enough members, for real.
I'm concerned about the Minecraft server.
I don't think I can make a server this big.
I don't...
I've actually never made a server before, so I'm going to...
Do my best.
Fukunawa, thanks for the MIME gifted!
Wait, I said stop!
Stop!
You
probably can't.
Oh my god you guys, stop playing.
What does...
Like...
Don't people do Minecraft servers for like their...
Patreon...
Um...
Things and stuff.
Poopy!
Thank you!
But how do they do it though?
Oh my gosh, thank you for the akatsuba, thank you.
Oh, CosmereSupport does it, thank you for the 15!
Nick, thank you for the 5!
Theon, thank you for the 10!
Thank you guys!
Digi, thank you for the 5!
Foxblade, thank you for the 5!
Billy Joe, thank you for the 10!
But how do...
Those are usually not $2 subs though.
Am I...
Did I make a mistake?
Oh, Lopenta, thank you for the 15!
And Epic...
What do I do then?
What do I do?
If I...
I can't change the price because...
Because...
Okay, this is the issue.
If I change the price, it kicks everyone out.
And if I...
If I make a higher tier, I think if people gift members, it will default to that tier!
So...
Like, I don't want it to be more expensive.
Like, I know that people, you know, VTuber fans probably have so many memberships that they're subscribed to.
And I want to be like the last person you think about, you know?
Especially if the...
Especially if there's some people who are like, oh, I'm also a Patreon member.
Then you definitely don't need to be spending so much on...
So much on a YouTube membership too.
Oh my god.
Guess we got the party.
What are you talking about?
How many members are we at?
I don't want to say.
I'm scared.
This is...
This is definitely the most I've ever had though.
Ever.
Congrats.
Thank you.
I think.
So, like seven?
Yeah, about.
Give or take.
You know.
About seven.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Thank you guys for joining.
Thank you guys so much.
This is why I didn't want to open on stream because I knew it would just be a free for all.
And I knew it would be chaos.
I didn't want to just be sitting here being like, thank you.
Thank you.
See you guys.
The floodgates are open.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
She hates thanking.
No, I just want to talk.
I want us to, you know, hang out.
Not just me being like, thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
My Kamiyoshi could never be the last VTuber I think about!
Stop!
It will be sad if your server is not called Outer Heaven.
Especially since you yourself are out of heaven, technically.
I will take that consideration, that naming consideration, to heart.
Yes.
I'm excited though.
Actually I have, next week, if I can get everything kind of set up, I have a stream planned.
For starting the server at least, and like...
Kind of building a little bit of stuff, so that we can...
I'm scared though.
I'm really scared.
I don't know, maybe I need to rethink this though.
Because I can't just be like, alright, first come first serve, get into the Minecraft server.
No, I don't know.
Well also, people can have access, but that doesn't mean everybody will be on at the same time, right?
So maybe it's actually okay.
There can be a max limit, but...
Everyone has access, not everyone...
The limit won't be...
The limit...
The limit does not exist.
Recently, on the plane, they had...
Did you guys know that they made a Mean Girls movie?
Well, they had a Mean Girls musical.
And then they made the Mean Girls movie musical.
I don't know.
I don't think I liked it very much.
The server will lag so bad.
I also missed an opportunity not calling Heaven Zanzibar.
Yes, let me travel back in time to before I played Metal Gear and say that I'm going to Zanzibar instead.
And everyone will be like, what?
That makes no sense.
Regina George is so pretty.
She is very pretty.
I don't know.
I just didn't like the...
I felt the songs were like kind of lacking.
I've never seen the musical before, by the way.
So...
I felt like the songs were lacking in like power, except for Regina usually.
But I don't know.
It was also...
It felt like...
Uncomfortable sometimes.
With some of the changes that they made, I was like, huh?
I don't get it.
Create a time paradox.
Ghost Babel.
I'm still trying to find a copy of Ghost Babel.
Ever play the Ace Combat 7 Special Mission DLC?
I have not played it yet.
Not yet.
E.P.
Mint.
I'm E.P.
Are you sleepy?
Sleepy, sleepy?
You'll probably never see More than 50% members log into the Minecraft server at once...
Yeah, but like...
I worry if I stream it?
Like, what if people would...
I wonder if there is a way that I may get so people can login while I'm streaming.
But like, I'll obviously login off stream.
But I wonder if there is a way that I could be able to fit in the Minecraft server for You're not allowed in while I'm streaming, but I'm also scared of what I'll see.
Oh my goodness, thank you for the birthday gift!
Thank you!
I have a lot to... I have a lot to learn and experiment with.
Please be patient with me.
Maybe have multiple servers?
Maybe.
But what if I show one server more love than the other?
That's not so good, right?
I don't know.
The servers are going to compete!
Oh my gosh, some people will be like, I'm server.
I'm servers and I'm servers.
I'm server Atorheaven.
And then they'll be like, oh my gosh, okay, we're going to organize... we're going to organize a takedown of Atorheaven.
We're going to storm in there and we're going to burn everybody's houses!
What if that happens?
There will be war!
Server Rex and Rey.
Server...
Server Shagohan.
Not the factions.
Made wars!
I can't stop yawning.
I don't know.
I'll get some advice from people and see what I do.
Luckily...
Luckily I didn't write Minecraft server access in the perks of joining membership, so...
So...
Um...
You know...
It...
We could just...
Pretend it never happened.
Give war a chance!
No!
You could do a lottery.
Maybe, but I would feel bad about it too.
I think.
I think I would feel bad about it too.
Please don't rush, take your time.
I will, thank you.
I will, I will.
Especially cause SOME PEOPLE KEEP GIFTING SO MANY MEMBERSHIPS!
Oh my god, your luck is abysmal.
But also, if it's a lottery...
I don't even know how I would distribute it.
Like how would I be like...
Okay...
I would have to...
I don't know.
I don't want to think about it.
Let's just...
Well, I'm saving that for futurement.
I don't need to worry about it.
Thank you guys for the gift.
Thank you!
Thank you guys, thank you.
Hmm...
Ugh...
But anyway...
Almost... wait...
As of today...
It has been one week...
of me back.
YIPPIE!
Oh my gosh!
Happy one week anniversary everybody!
Happy one week to me!
Happy one week...
to me!
Please...
Stop the...
gifting...
of memberships!
Happy one week...
to...
me!
Oh!
I can't do high notes anymore.
My throat...
I wonder if it will ever recover.
Maybe I need to drink more honey stuff.
I have in here...
Well, this is ginger and yuzu.
I guess that doesn't really help.
Before in the past, I used to...
Still sick girl?
I don't think I'm still sick.
I think it's just that...
My voice is...
Since my voice was so damaged before...
It's taking a long time to recover.
Or, you know...
That was also...
another reason I took some time.
Sorry, I'm trying to get...
This voice...
This voice mint out.
Another reason I took...
so long...
Not took so long...
Another reason I took some time off...
The two months in Japan...
Was because I wanted to rest my voice.
Because...
Even prior to that...
I've been having some...
Some issues with...
With my...
Not my voice giving out, but like...
I could feel it...
Like getting a little weaker.
So...
But I think I just need to...
Take better care of it too.
And you totally did that, right?
You'd be surprised!
I would go to...
Idol shows...
And I wouldn't scream so loud.
Like I would do like...
If I did calls, I would...
Do them like in my normal voice now.
I would go so like loud and crazy.
So...
Didn't you go to karaoke?
Yeah, sometimes.
I only went like...
Like four or five times.
I didn't go that often.
What do you mean...
What do you mean?
I was being good!
I was, I promise.
But yeah...
That's a lot of times.
In two months?
Five times is not that much.
I think.
I'd go...
I remember the first time I went.
And then...
You know, thinking about it now...
I think I went...
By myself to karaoke...
Every time.
I really wanted to go to Pasela.
Pasela is like one of my favorite...
Karaoke places.
Because they have this yummy honey toast.
That I like to get.
Thank you for the five gifted thank you.
Your voice needs roughly a week...
To heal between heavy overuse-ish.
Yeah...
But what about...
How about sickness?
Pasela is awesome.
Yeah!
But...
And then they have the big honey toast.
And then they have the small honey toast.
But the small honey toast...
I don't like it so much.
Because it's like...
It's...
It's too hard.
In my opinion.
Thank you for the five gifted...
And...
But you need to get...
The big honey toast...
You need to go with friends or else...
You'll not be able to finish it all.
So...
So many memberships...
You're telling me!
Oh my gosh, thank you for the...
I meant I hope your spiritual reawakening...
Reawakening goes well.
Take care, sweetie.
I'm sure you will do great.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Nah, I win.
They're big though.
Hold on, let me get a picture.
Let me get a picture for you guys.
They're so yummy.
Pasela honey toast.
I wonder if I can find one.
Okay.
This one has like a person in the background.
So you can kind of get like the scale.
Oh my gosh, it's so cool.
If I talk about something, I can just show you guys.
Wowie.
Wowie!
Okay, I just googled this.
So I don't know who that person is.
But look how big!
Oh my gosh, it looks so delicious.
And it's like that nice thick toast too.
And it's like...
I love...
Oh, it's so good.
It's so yummy.
And they have different kinds.
Like this one...
Holy cannoli.
Look at this one.
Oh, it's so small.
Look at that!
It looks so good!
Oh my gosh.
And each of those little parts...
Some of the toast, the bread...
Oh my gosh.
I really wanted to go and get one.
Oh!
Here!
They show the...
They show the small size too.
Why is it so tiny?
But it's like not the same.
Because I like the softness of the toast.
You know?
But yeah.
This is at Pase La Karaoke places in Japan.
Yummy.
So small.
So tiny.
And that is toast?
Yeah.
It's toast.
Cubic food.
That's big?
What, the honey toast?
Are you kidding me?
It's huge!
It's also filled, you guys.
It's like... it's so big.
Hold on.
Let me see if I can find...
Uh... I mean...
Uh...
It's so big!
Honey toast...
Yes!
That's what we're talking about!
Bye, Charmin!
I've had this one before.
Hold on.
Oh, it's a P&G!
This one.
I've had this one before.
Yummy, yummy, yummy.
Oh my gosh!
I'm thrilled!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
I love cinnamoroll.
I love, love, love cinnamoroll.
But also, recently...
I've been pretty into Kogi Myun.
I think she's really cute.
But also...
There was a new...
Well, I say new...
I think he was released last year.
But he's like...
He's like...
Um...
What's the word?
He's a ghost that draws...
Hold on.
Ghost.
Hanamaru Obake.
He's so cute!
I'm like...
You're just like me.
You're a ghost.
Hold on.
Save image.
Show you guys.
Look!
Look how cute!
Oh, he's so cute!
Hanamaru Obake.
Hanamaru is like...
You know...
Those swirly...
Teachers like...
Draw like 100% on your homework.
It's the big swirly.
That's what...
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
There's a picture.
This, this, this, this, this.
This, this, this.
You see the hanamaru?
On the ground.
Yeah.
So, Hanamaru Obake.
It's literally you!
It's me!
You guys are getting 100% in school?
Man...
Did I talk about my...
Okay, I'm gonna talk a little bit about the...
Japan school I went to.
Because...
The Japanese school I went to a little bit.
Um...
I think I mentioned before how I don't regret going at all.
I had so much fun and I learned a lot.
I don't remember if I talked about this on stream before.
You didn't really mention much?
I'm not going to say the name or anything, obviously.
The reason I would choose not to go back...
What kind of school was it?
It was a Japanese learning school.
The reason I wouldn't go back is because...
Well, first of all, they were very flexible.
I originally wanted 6 months, but they were like, we can't get you for that.
But we have 2 months we can give you.
And I was like, okay!
That works fine.
But when I entered the class...
There were people there that...
That...
There were people there that had been there for like...
Months and months and months before me.
And so...
Wasn't the housing situation an issue too?
No, not really.
They helped me get a place.
Which was...
The only issue was it was 20 minutes away from the train station.
And you guys...
I scammed myself.
Ugh...
I still...
I'm still so angry about it.
Um...
Sounds like quite a walk.
I love walking, so I actually don't mind.
It was only an issue when I was...
When I was...
Late in the mornings.
JR pass?
No.
Not the JR pass.
I got the teikiken.
I got the commuter pass.
Which is like, if you're staying in Japan for a long time...
Highly recommend it.
If you're like...
Either going to...
To...
Like, you know...
Like for me, I'm going to the same place every day.
And so...
When you get the pass, you choose...
Two different stations.
And every station in between that...
Is also...
Included in the pass.
So...
It's super duper duper super handy.
I got one once too.
When I actually worked in Akihabara.
For a little bit.
And I got it from my school to...
This was years ago.
But I got it from my school to Akihabara.
So I could go to Akihabara as often as I want.
I mean, I would say free.
But I paid for it.
So...
But yeah, the teikiken.
And so...
I got it.
Oh, how do I say...
Okay.
The station's name...
Was kind of weird.
I don't know how to describe it without saying it exactly.
Um...
But...
When I was putting in the stations...
I got the station that I was...
The station that I went to...
By my apartment.
To...
And I thought I put in...
My station...
That I got off for school.
But no.
I put in...
I put in a...
I didn't realize that I...
Missed a part on it.
And so...
I paid like...
A hundred and fifty dollars for it.
Because I had it last...
Two months.
And um...
No, I'm sorry.
Just a month.
It was just a month.
Because I got it kind of late.
Because I was trying to find...
Right now there's like a SuicaPass shortage.
So I was trying to find a place that...
Would print it.
Um... I could not find a place that...
Would even like...
Allow me to get it.
So...
It discounted...
My...
My um...
The amount that I spent.
But ultimately I ended up like...
Paying double.
For...
For my...
For my tickets.
And only... and then because...
Because the...
The train was also weird...
The trains in between...
The stations in between...
It only counted...
Some of them.
I know.
I'm sorry.
I'm being very vague.
Because I don't want to like just give away where I went and everything.
But...
It was...
It was so... I was so angry at myself...
And I realized...
I was so mad.
I was like...
It was my fault.
I...
I should have double checked.
Salty commuter's ambling mishap.
Yeah.
I feel this frustration.
Scamming yourself sucks.
It does.
So...
If you get the commuter pass...
Definitely double...
Triple check.
And...
Yeah.
Don't be like me.
Luckily...
You know, for me...
I could afford it but...
If... you know...
What if I was in a worse position?
I would have been like...
I would have been really suffering.
So...
It's okay.
We're no strangers to scam.
I honestly don't know if I could have gotten a refund.
But...
I felt bad about...
Wasting the pass.
If that were the case.
You know what I mean?
I don't know.
I didn't wanna...
But yeah.
It's okay.
We live and learn.
Or die and learn.
In my case.
But yeah.
About the school...
I...
Um...
I went in...
Where some of the students were there.
Many, many months before me.
And so...
You know, in the textbook we were learning from...
It was like lessons...
I don't remember.
20... let's just say...
25 to 50.
Okay?
So they...
Learned from lesson 25.
The people that were in the class.
I learned...
Well, yes.
Then we had this one big test that...
Was the entirety...
Of the book.
So we took that test.
Which was...
Lessons 25 through 50.
I came in at lesson 40.
So...
I was like...
No way...
This sucks...
It sucked so much.
And because...
You know...
I...
When I properly learned Japanese...
You know, that was so long ago.
I forgot so much of it.
Especially like...
Tiny things too.
Like the correct way to use this...
This...
Form or whatever.
So I was like...
I'm obviously...
It was just hard trying to catch up.
But I'm glad because now...
I'm back into like...
The mindset of studying.
And...
I did learn a lot of like...
Kegel.
And...
Yeah, so it was good.
I do wish also there was like...
More talking in the class.
I don't know.
I feel like that's so important.
It's so funny though.
On my first day...
It was a pretty small class.
And someone...
Someone...
Someone asked me...
Like...
First my teacher was like...
Oh, Minto!
Your voice is so cute!
I was like...
No, no, no, no, no.
And someone in the class, this guy, he was just like...
Are you a Vtuber?
Oh, no.
First he asked...
Are you a voice actor?
And I was like... No.
And then he goes...
And then...
I was like... No.
They were like... You've never done any voice acting work?
Like your voice is kind of unique.
I was like... No.
No.
I...
I just... I don't know.
And then...
While I was leaving, because it was at the end of class...
They were like...
The guy, he was just like... She's probably a Vtuber.
And...
It was so funny because...
There was a...
There was a... I ended up like...
Him and this other girl...
We would go and get lunch together after class.
And like... They would...
He kept... He would keep asking me...
He'd be like... Are you a Vtuber?
Are you a Vtuber?
And I'm like... No, no, no, no, no.
And...
I think at one point I was like... You know what?
Maybe I'll mess with him a little bit.
Because he would ask me...
He would be like... Are you part of this company?
And I was like... No, no, no, no, no.
And...
Like he asked if I was...
Part of Hololive.
And I was like... No!
He didn't know Vtubers at all.
He was just like... That's the only...
That's the only thing I know.
And so I was like...
I was like... No!
But at one point I was like...
You know what?
I am gonna mess with him.
I was like... You know what?
Sorry.
I was like...
I am a Vtuber.
And he had a bet going...
With another guy in our class.
That I was a...
That I was a Vtuber.
And he was like... Yes!
I'm gonna tell him.
I was like... No, no, no, no.
Don't tell him.
Just like... You know...
Kind of keep him on his toes or whatever.
And then...
They would...
He would try to ask me stuff.
And the girl too.
She was just like...
I can't tell if you are lying or not.
And I was like... What?
What do you mean?
And...
He would be like... If you are really a Vtuber...
Tell me a story.
And I was just like... I can't tell you any story.
Sorry.
I was like... I can't.
You know...
That's too private.
I don't want to be found out.
And...
And then... Okay.
This whole... The whole like...
Two months I was keeping this up.
And on the very last day...
We went and...
The three of us went and got coffee.
And he looked at me and he was just like...
You know what?
You really had me going.
I really thought that you were a Vtuber.
And I was like... Gotcha!
I was so... It was so silly.
I was like... No way.
They just didn't believe me at all.
Like she...
She was so... They were both very nice.
But...
Like... When I say...
I'm an introvert...
Like I am a true introvert.
They were more introverted than me.
So I'm the one like trying to start all the conversations.
And I'm just like...
Uh...
The weather... It's so hot today.
Like...
Like... It was crazy.
It was crazy how much I was like...
Um...
How much I was like...
Oh my god.
I'm having to pretend I'm an extrovert here.
It would be a little awkward.
It would be.
Because we would just be eating in silence for a long time.
But it was good.
It was still a fun time.
I got to...
Do a lot.
And uh...
Um...
Quiet classmates.
It would be so funny because we would be like...
Sitting in silence in our classroom.
There was only ever...
Six of us at the most.
In a class.
At a time.
Yeah.
And we would be sitting there in silence.
And we would hear like the class next door.
Like...
What do you mean?
Stop making my own joke.
Shut up!
We would hear the class next to us laugh.
And like be really loud and energetic.
And we were all just sitting there like...
How did we all...
How did we all get in...
How did this class...
Be only introverts?
I don't understand.
Laugh...
Uh...
Ha ha ha...
But yeah...
Laugh...
Cast lighting is fun!
Oh... wait...
Laugh...
Uh...
But yeah...
So...
I did enjoy my time.
I don't think like... you know...
I'm not... I never thought like, oh this was such a waste of money.
I think I had a good experience.
And I always wanted to...
Why are you guys spamming?
Stop it!
Thank you for the 10 gifts!
Thank you!
Are you planning to take the JLPT?
No, I don't think so.
I don't think so.
Maybe if I studied specifically for them.
But it wasn't that kind of class either.
It wasn't like, okay, you are taking N2 class.
It wasn't anything like that.
Or whatever, so...
Just to get functional.
Yeah, yeah.
I would much rather like...
feel confident and feel good in my abilities than like...
I mean, obviously like studying...
would enhance that too, of course.
Like studying for the JLPT, I mean.
But...
But I would rather just be like...
Oh yeah, I can talk and hang out.
And I don't need a piece of paper to...
to say that or not.
I took the exam just to see if I'm already on that level.
That's okay too.
Like, if you want to take it, go for it.
But...
Yeah.
Still, I'm still not so Nihongo Jozu, but...
You know...
I'm Ganbarimasu-ing my way through life.
Did you get all Bs?
No, I got good grades.
I got good grades.
Studying Kanji is so difficult.
It can be.
I...
Honestly, so I...
have found the most help with WaniKani...
for Kanji.
But if you're...
wanting to know how to write it...
It's impossible.
Like...
I can... I can't...
I can't write anything.
I can see so many Kanji and recognize them and read them and everything, but I cannot...
write it at all.
But WaniKani is really...
has been the most...
helpful for me, at least.
Just use my keyboard.
Exactly!
Exactly.
I mean, there's already...
Isn't that an issue in Japan too?
There's people who don't know how to write so much anymore.
But...
Yeah.
I wonder...
Is that like an issue in like...
You know...
Like in...
Like in China.
Is that also an issue?
Where so many people...
Type?
That they can't...
Be Hongo?
That they can't write so much anymore?
Yeah, it is.
What is this?
It's an issue in the USA too, to be honest.
Okay.
So...
Kind of true.
Yeah.
My dad can barely write anymore from living in the States.
Yup.
This...
Yeah.
I had to write everything though.
I have...
I have calluses on my...
On my hands from holding pencils.
I had to...
I had to hold a pencil.
My handwriting is so awful.
It's so...
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I realize with the...
With like some of the Patreon stuff, I have to come up with a signature.
I don't...
I don't have a signature.
What do I do?
What do I...
Thank
you for the raid!
Now...
I don't have a signature at all.
I don't even know...
how to...
I don't know what to come up with at all.
Do I...
I'm gonna copy Hanamaru Obake.
I'm just gonna make it like a...
It's like that iCuts episode.
It's exactly like that iCuts episode!
But my handwriting isn't so fancy.
So I need something kind of simple.
I don't know.
Okay, I'm gonna look up.
Idol sign.
How to make an idol sign.
Wait, I need one that starts with an M.
I don't know what...
A heart could be an M, right?
Maybe.
I don't know.
Clues, thanks for the Minecrafted!
If it's upside down...
No!
Hold on, I'm gonna... let me open up Paint.
Let's workshop...
Oh, wait.
Let's workshop this a little bit.
We workshop, we workshop.
Okay.
Even though this is on a mouse.
So it might... it's already gonna be ugly.
But don't worry about it.
Okay.
Crop, Crop, Crop, Crop.
Crop, Crop, Crop.
Okay.
There we go.
I'm looking up idol signatures right now.
I'm not gonna copy anyone.
Wait, this one also has an M.
And it's cute.
Ehhh.
Like a...
Why?
I is so difficult.
Ehhh.
Signed in ectoplasm.
But I want the...
Okay, hold on.
Maybe if we do like that.
I-N-T And then we...
And then we turn it into a wisp.
Uh, with the...
And...
Oh, the cat ears.
Hold on.
Perfection.
No!
You guys have to give me feedback!
Looks like a whale.
I thought it was a whale.
Aww, man.
Okay.
See, this is why we're workshopping.
This is why we're workshopping.
Um...
Catfish.
No!
Like, I'm looking up this one.
This one has like...
I...
I hate cursive N.
So we're not gonna do it.
Mint.
And then... Oh!
Uh...
I feel like this would look better if it was like...
In a cute collar...
And like...
Oh!
He's back!
Hmm...
I like mine, like...
Really...
Big and curly, you know?
The whale is by an onion.
What to do?
Oh, wait!
What if I do...
Okay, I've seen ones like this too.
Where it's like a big...
You know, like that.
That's the M.
It doesn't have to make perfect sense.
Like, it can be like, you know...
And then we could...
I and T.
And like, then here...
It's me!
And then here...
And um...
Is that in Among Us?
No!
You're not seeing the vision.
Hold on, let's change this one.
I'm gonna make it a little bit more exciting.
Like um...
Like that.
Um...
It's a Diglett.
Oh, now it's just Wobbuffet!
Would it be better if we did it in Kana?
So, hi Mitt.
First time seeing you.
Hi, Coke's Metal!
Thank you!
I could try and do it.
My name is spelled in Katakana.
Not Hiragana.
So...
I'm thinking Katakana would look...
Ugly.
Like, hold on.
Like...
Cause Katakana is this.
Mi...
Nn...to.
I can't even write it well.
Mi...
Nn...
To.
There's no way to make this look cute.
I think.
As a signature.
Must be Hiragana.
Mi...
Kana is so much cuter.
I'm such a fool.
Why didn't I write my name in Hiragana?
I'm gonna change it today.
Mi...
Nn...to.
Hmm...
Mi...
Nn...to.
Not Mi...
Give us your best...
Wobbuffet!
...
Look at this one.
This is what...
Hold on, I'm gonna save it.
This is what we're aiming for, you guys.
This level of...
This level.
...
This...
Why is it so big?
...
I do kind of like the...
The direction...
This direction.
If I don't make it a Wobbuffet...
...
I think it could be kind of cute.
Hold on...
There's some that are like this.
...
Maybe like a...
Maybe like a Miffy face.
Miffy!
I love Miffy.
...
Give it...
Sleeves?
Arms?
I don't think that'll work.
I think it makes it look so ugly.
...
I think it makes it look ugly.
That's okay, though.
...
Every time you say Minto, it sounds like Mentos.
Let's see this one.
...
Wait, that's actually not so bad!
With the little tongue out!
...
Like me!
We're onto something.
And then I could add like some...
...
I would put like little sparklies maybe.
I think it would look better if it's like...
You know how like in Idolmaster when they show their signatures they're like all sparkly...
They're glowing and they're all sparkly in the eyes.
Make it look like Gengar.
...
Maybe it would look...
I mean also it's drawn on my...
With my mouse, so...
We're workshopping it.
It's my signature.
You don't have to like it.
Except people who are getting it on a postcard and have to look at it every time you see it.
You're gonna look at this guy's little face and you're gonna be like, oh no.
Oh no.
...
Idolmaster signatures are nice.
Yeah, that's what I'm looking at.
I'm looking at just like idol signatures in general.
For inspiration.
...
But some of...
Most of them are like so complex because they do...
...
They do like a lot...
They have like the kanji incorporated and things like that.
And then it's easier I feel like with hiragana because it's so...
It's so loopy.
...
Like a...
Like if I did...
Like if I did the minto in...
Like a...
Wrong way.
Something like that.
And then you have like this.
And like...
You know...
Or here...
And then like that for the toe.
They're always so crazy, you know?
And then...
And then when you do it...
Like that...
And then it has like a face in here...
Like a...
...
Kind of like that.
Like they always go so crazy with them.
...
The face is essential.
For my branding.
...
Can't you try to write mint normally as your signature?
No!
...
No.
Must be perfect from the beginning.
...
It can't just be my ugly handwriting.
It has to be special.
...
Can we make custom mint signatures in your art tag?
You can!
But I prefer to make my own.
So...
If you do, I will not use it.
I can tell you that now.
But I appreciate it.
I just can't.
I won't use it.
Because I prefer to come up with it on my own.
...
I have to add a doodle for Pizazz.
That's what the ghost is for.
...
I think I will go with...
I will start with this.
It kind of looks like Funashi.
...
Minto with Papyrus.
Have you ever filled out the document?
The documents you signed?
... Instead of drawing a signature?
You can type your signature.
And it counts as your signature.
...
It's me with the...
Me with the...
...
Papyrus.
If I were to write mint, I would have to be done so...
Here's an example.
It's so hard with these ones.
...
A lot of them are their kanji.
But just to give you an idea.
Let's see if there's some Idolmaster ones.
...
Riamo's is so cute.
So cute.
Oh my, she's also got that little eyes in it.
That's so funny.
Then...
Here.
Mine fits right in, you guys.
...
It's like...
It just fits perfectly right in there.
Oh my gosh.
Huey!
...
Oh my gosh, Huey.
Thank you for the 50.
...
I like the really...
Like...
The really...
Maybe if I...
Oh...
I don't know.
...
I'll figure it out.
You should be on this boat.
Itsumine Yuika's signature is the best.
Wait, which one is that one?
...
Oh.
Oh wait, there it is.
...
Wait, is it?
It's so cute.
Oh wait!
It has the hat!
Oh my gosh, that's so cute.
...
That's so cute.
I'll show you guys too.
...
Like, look at that.
They're so crazy.
...
But, and then of course the kanji always like makes it so much more...
See, that's why I was like, oh, you know, I can do like stars or whatever in it, little circles.
Make, just dress it up a little bit.
I love, I love circular autographs.
Maybe because they look so, um...
Maybe because they look so nice on Shikishi.
...
But like, you know, this, this, the...
the busyness like just shows up so well.
Circu... Yeah, like a stamp!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
It is very aesthetically pleasing.
But with my name, I don't really have any circles.
Which is why I would have to make the mint, or the M like the biggest circular part maybe.
Unless I like circled my name and wrote, wrote it on the inside.
But...
...
Is there a kanji for mint?
Maybe, but...
But, you could do minto and have the O go all around.
Oh, you're cooking?
You're cooking?
...
So like...
I do like having it like a butt M too.
Wait, oh no.
...
Min...
... to.
...
Um...
Thank you for the thank you, thank you!
Min... to!
Why can't I?
Min...
... to!
...
Just looks like I circled my name.
This is hard.
Well...
Whatever I come up with, you guys will see.
...
On the postcards.
I suppose.
You guys will see.
On the postcards.
...
I think...
Oh my gosh, it's already 10.30.
I think I'm gonna head to bed.
I think I'm going to head out.
Tomorrow, I have a tomodachi live.
...
Tomodachi live.
Yeah, we'll create some crazy situations.
...
Hopefully.
Last time I played, none of my people got married.
So that's the goal.
I wonder what's the most cursed pairing we can get.
...
I wonder.
Yes, yes, yes.
Thank you!
Thank you guys for enjoying this.
Well, maybe enjoying.
For...
...
Hanging out with me and participating in this cursed game.
Fassad was so silly.
It's free, by the way.
If you ever want to try it out yourself.
Just google it.
You can download it for free.
It is free.
You can do it however.
You can be like...
trying to get the most cursed combination ever.
...
Um.
From divorced, to trying to get married.
Oh my gosh!
We should make them in...
in tomodachi live!
...
Oh.
Hey Mint.
It's me piccolo.
Did you know your initials are MF?
...
Thanks Piccolo.
What you just call me?
Thank you guys for hanging out with me until the very end.
Really really appreciate it.
I guess I'll see you guys later.
I'll see you guys tomorrow.
Otsu... Oh!
Play... Play... Play me out!
Play me out!
Play me... Play me out!
Thanks for the pink!
Since we have the Bustin' emote now...
We can... You can use it.
You can use the Bustin'...
OtsuBust!
OtsuMito!
If there's something strange...
Sleeping in your bed...
Let me tell you something...
You can hear it, right?
Okay, yeah.
Let me tell you something...
Bustin' makes me feel good!
garment
Thanks for...
Watching the stream.
Feel good, feel good, feel good!
Freaky Ghost Maid!
Freaky Masked Man!
Freaky McMahon Baby!
Why can't I remember?
Let me sleep in your bed!
Freaky Divorce Baby!
I ain't afraid of no art!
I ain't afraid of no painting!
An Invisible Bartender!
Freaky Ghost Bartender!
Yeah, yeah!
I ain't afraid of no melon!
Drink water, everybody!
A soup up for the Freaky Ghost Maid!
Thank you!
Thank you guys for all the donations!
Thank you for all the stream labs!
Thank you for all the...
Thank you for all the donated, gifted!
Thank you for all the super chats!
Thank you for all the support!
You guys have been absolutely insane.
I'm a little overwhelmed.
Now I'm reevaluating...
Oh my god!
Stupid Shark!
Thank you for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
Bust em!
Makes me feel good!
Feel good!
Bust em makes me feel good!
Atsuminto!
Oh, it just happened.
Oh, it just went to the next song.
Sorry.
Atsuminto!
Bye bye!
Thank you for watching!
Bye!